la directrice générale Monsieur le
Secrétaire général mais chers collègues
nous avons le grand plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui mesdames Christelle Edman
nouvelle directrice générale du groupe
Orange accompagné de Monsieur Nicolas
Guérin secrétaire général madame vous
avez pris vos fonctions au mois d'avril
dernier et je tiens naturellement à
souligner parce que c'est important vous
êtes à la première femme à diriger
orange le groupe Orange et vous êtes la
seconde femme à diriger une entreprise
du CAC 40 voilà je fais la petite
remarque toujours importante voir
comment les choses évoluent avant de
vous donner la parole puis de permettre
à mes collègues de soumettre leurs
questions je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur trois points principaux
orange bien sûr c'est avant tout un
opérateur à des activités d'opérateurs
d'infrastructures et de réseaux de
télécommunications mais le groupe est
désormais multiservices avec des
activités de finances des activités
bancaires des activités numériques à
destination à la fois des particuliers
et des entreprises vous avez un chiffre
d'affaires qui est estimée sur ferreur
de ma part à 42 milliards et demi en
2022 vous avez 271 millions de clients
dans 26 pays et la croissance de votre
groupe est désormais davantage soutenu
par ces activités dans les autres pays
européens qu'en France en Afrique et au
Moyen-Orient mais cet après tout naturel
alors que le groupe poursuit la
diversification de ses activités son
expansion géographique je veux aborder
avec vous votre coeur d'activité à
savoir votre rôle d'opérateur de réseau
en France le secteur des
télécommunications est aujourd'hui bien
sûr à une période charnière en France
avec l'extinction programmée à l'horizon
2030 du fameux réseau cuivre dont orange
et l'opérateur historique et
l'accélération du développement de la
fibre dont la généralisation est prévue
pour demain matin c'est à dire pour 2025
dans cette période de transition les
inquiétudes les mécontentements des
usagers des entreprises des
collectivités sont assez multiples
alors nous avons des interrogations
notamment sur l'extension du réseau
cuivre 20 millions de personnes
utilisent encore ce réseau
principalement pour la téléphonie fixe
la DSL dans les zones peu dense mais
également pour les traitements des
appels d'urgence et cette transition
représente un triple des filles
industriel technologique sociale pour
notre pays d'ici 2025 nous estimons que
pratiquement 700 000 foyers ne
disposeront pas de la fibre optique en
raison de la complexité de leur
raccordement réseau alors même que
l'ARCEP a fixé pour sa part un critère
de 100% de locaux raccordable à la fibre
optique sur le territoire d'une commune
pour pouvoir fermer le réseau cuivre
quels seront donc les précautions les
mesures concrètes qui seront prises par
Orange pour effectuer les raccordements
complexes qui sont nécessaires et bien
sûr informer ces abonnés du coût
financier réel de ces raccordements une
partie pouvant prix être à la charge
pardon direct des particuliers la
transition numérique qui s'opère ne doit
laisser personne de côté et au Sénat
naturellement nous sommes très soucieux
d'assurer une connectivité jusqu'au
dernier maître et jusqu'au dernier
abonné la période actuelle exacerbe
également les rivalités et les tensions
entre opérateurs parfois nous voyons
nous sur le terrain au détriment de la
qualité de service et du déploiement du
réseau et de la qualité du déploiement
du réseau mais aussi peut-être détriment
d'une juste concurrence vous allez vous
exprimer là-dessus dans le secteur des
télécommunications les autres opérateurs
ont d'ores et déjà fait part de leur
crainte que la fermeture du réseau
cuivre constitue un avantage
concurrentiel permettant à Orange de
proposer ses propres offres commerciales
quelles sont donc les garanties que vous
apportez pour maintenir un juste niveau
de concurrence lors du déploiement de la
fibre les autres opérateurs contestent
également les perspectives de hausse des
tarifs des groupages qu'il verse à
Orange pour l'utilisation de son réseau
cuivre dont l'entretien doit quand même
être maintenu annuellement malgré un
démantèlement prévu à partir de 2030
l'opérateur Bouygues même récemment
porté plainte contre Orange à ce sujet
bien sûr vous ne vous exprimerez pas sur
ce sujet particulier mais plus
généralement comment arriver vous à
justifier la hausse des tarifs de
dégroupage en même temps à garantir un
minimum d'entretien et de qualité du
réseau cuivre pour les autres opérateurs
qui l'utilisent le tout en maintenant
une concurrence juste et équitable vous
expliquerez comment vous marchez sur
cette ligne de crête en parlant d'équité
il y a un autre sujet sur lequel le
secteur des télécommunications est
défavorisé c'est celui de la
contribution des plateformes au
déploiement des réseaux de
télécommunications en 2020 je rappelle
que les opérateurs d'infrastructures
auront investi plus de 12 milliards 12
milliards 6 précisément essentiellement
pour assurer le déploiement du réseau
très haut débit de la fibre optique et
les premières installations 5G or la
moitié du trafic Internet provient de 5
grandes entreprises qu'on citera pas ici
mais qu'on connaît qui sont des
fournisseurs et des diffuseurs de
contenus le montant annuel
d'investissement supplémentaire que
devront réaliser le opérateur d'ici 2030
pour s'adapter à la hausse du trafic est
estimée de nouveau à 10 milliards
d'euros et ce bois ce besoin croissant
d'investissement soulève des enjeux de
souveraineté dans la mesure où les
grandes entreprises américaines du
numérique sont les principaux
bénéficiaires de ces investissements
auxquels elle ne contribue pas finissent
financièrement de surcroît cet
investissement privé largement soutenu
par des investissements publics
nationaux et européens dans ce contexte
la commission des affaires économiques
s'est exprimée en faveur de
l'instauration d'une contribution des
plateformes numériques au financement
des réseaux de télécommunications dans
le cadre de notre récent rapport sur la
souveraineté numérique dont j'étais avec
Amel gaker et Franck Montauger mes
collègues rapporteurs depuis l'organe de
régulation européen des communications
électroniques comme plusieurs
régulateurs nationaux s'exprimer en
défaveur de l'instauration d'une telle
contribution notamment au regard du
respect de la neutralité d'Internet nous
sommes donc extrêmement curieux Madame
la Directrice générale de vous entendre
également sur ce point voilà quelques
sujets voilà liminaires sur les
interrogations de la commission je vais
bien sûr vous donner la parole et
ensuite je la donnerai au sénateurs qui
veulent s'exprimer et en premier lieu à
notre collègue Patrick chaise voilà qui
spécialiste du numérique voilà
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je vous remercie
de me recevoir et je suis très heureuse
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui dans le
double objectif de revenir sur les
grandes réalisations d'oranges et de
vous présenter les défis importants qui
sont encore collectivement devant nous
Vous avez adressé dans vos propos à un
certain nombre d'entre eux un peu plus
de six mois après que le conseil
d'administration d'orange m'a confié les
minantes mission de piloter le premier
opérateur français cette audition est
pour moi une première je voudrais
commencer par dire que la France peut
être fière de son opérateur historique
car parmi eux les opérateurs historiques
seuls trois sont encore leaders en
Europe Dutch Télécom en Allemagne
téléphonica en Espagne et enfin orange
en France fort de ces 136 500 salariés
dans le monde dont 75000 en France
orange est aujourd'hui présent dans 26
pays 8 en Europe 18 en Afrique et au
Moyen-Orient nous y opérons au service
de plus de 250 millions de clients
particuliers en outre notre filiale
Orange Business Services accompagne nos
clients surprise partout dans le monde
en 2021 nos activités ont généré un
chiffre d'affaires de 42,5 milliards
d'euros comme vous l'avez rappelé en
train légère croissance par rapport à
2020 croissance de plus 0,5%. avant de
prendre le temps de répondre à vos
questions je souhaiterais dans un
premier temps revenir sur les
difficultés que nous rencontrons en tant
qu'opérateur Télécom face au contrats
réglementaires au niveau européen comme
au niveau national je vous exposerai
ensuite en quoi Orange opérateur citoyen
et locomotive de l'aménagement numérique
du territoire en France se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation intenable
face aux injonctes injonctions
contradictoires auxquelles nous devons
faire face en dépit d'une grande
résilience du secteur qui n'est plus à
démontrer les disruptions majeures que
nous avons connues et leur retard des
régulateurs européens et français pour
s'adapter à ce nouvel environnement
nous place désormais à la croisée des
chemins les 30 dernières années ont été
marquées par une succession de
disruption majeure dans le secteur des
télécoms de l'ouverture à la concurrence
à la naissance puis à la croissance
ultra rapide d'Internet et de nouveaux
services over au top les besoins en
matière de connectivité connaissent
aussi une révolution sur le marché
entreprise quel que soit leur taille et
le secteur d'activité nos clients se
détournent des solutions traditionnelles
de téléphonie au profit de nouveaux
services soutenus par des logiciels et
des solutions informatiques utilisant
l'infrastructure réseau sans en
supporter les investissements
nécessaires la régulation ne semble pas
avoir suffisamment pris en compte ces
différentes lames de fonds et leurs
impacts irréversibles sur les télécoms
face à l'explosion de l'économie
numérique elle continue de se concentrer
sur les opérateurs
ignorant les transferts de valeur qui
s'opèrent vers les nouveaux acteurs bien
sûr l'innovation est la première raison
du succès fulgurante ses services ils se
sont cependant aussi imposés à la faveur
d'un modèle abusivement dit de gratuité
très rémunérateur pour ces acteurs et
les grandes plateformes assis sur deux
piliers le transfert et l'exploitation
des données personnelles des
utilisateurs finaux et le transfert des
coûts de distribution des services de
ces opérateurs vers nous opérateurs
télécom des impacts pour notre activité
sont double commercialement nous devons
résister à l'arrivée sur le marché de
nouvelles offres gourmandes en capacités
réseau tandis que nous en supportons par
ailleurs financièrement une partie des
coûts le résultat est une situation
structurellement déséquilibrée entre les
opérateurs et les fournisseurs de
services numériques qui offrent les
mêmes services sans être soumis au même
règle alors que nos réseaux n'ont jamais
été aussi vitaux nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui dans une situation
paradoxale au péril de l'investissement
dans les infrastructures et de la
qualité de service permettez-moi de
revenir plus en détail sur l'équation
financière du Groupe Orange en France
nous partageons avec vous l'objectif
ambitieux d'apporter à toutes les
Françaises et tous les Français une
connexion à des réseaux très haut débits
modernes avec une qualité de service
adéquate quand on mesure l'ampleur des
réalisations en termes de réseaux très
haut débit en France qui sont sans
équivalent en Europe je crois qu'il faut
le dire et que nous pouvons
collectivement être fiers de la tâche
accomplie
c'est le cachet orange ou la
mobilisation des équipes sur la question
de la fibre optique est exceptionnelle
partout en France depuis plusieurs
années nous déploions dans quelques
semaines notre 20 millionième prise sur
les 33 millions que compte notre pays
ainsi 60% des prises déployées en France
l'ont été par nos équipes et avec nos
partenaires industriels essentiellement
sur nos fonds propres et à nos risques
si le plan France trait au débit a
rempli ses promesses orange n'est pas
étrangée il en est même la locomotive
nous sommes conscients qu'il reste
beaucoup à faire pour atteindre
l'objectif d'une généralisation de la
fibre optique en 2025 c'est-à-dire
demain et les prises encore à déployer
ne sont pas les plus simples dans le
même temps nous sommes encore confrontés
au défi de l'entretien et de la
maintenance simultanée de deux réseaux
filaires le réseau cuivre historique et
le nouveau réseau fibre
nous devons par ailleurs investir chaque
année des centaines de millions d'euros
pour absorber la croissance du trafic
mobile d'environ 35% par an
principalement soutenu par les services
de cinq fournisseurs de contenu
principaux qui représentent 80% de la
bande passante et s'arrange ainsi la
valeur de nos investissements sans y
contribuer
dernière étape du déploiement de la
fibre la fermeture du cuivre vous en
avez parlé l'entretien et la maintenance
des réseaux les politiques publiques
doivent adresser ces défis les relevés
commandes de se pencher sur l'équation
économique des infrastructures qui est
de plus en plus complexe après un âge
d'or de la filière Télécom en France
intégrée et solidaire piloté par une
politique industrielle appuyée et une
vision globale nous faisons désormais
face à un fonctionnement en silo des
politiques publiques d'un côté des
autorités administratives indépendantes
ont entre leurs mains une partie de
l'équation de l'autre le gouvernement et
le législateur mènent les politiques
publiques sans avoir les outils à leurs
mains personne n'apparaît encore capable
d'avoir une vision sur l'équation
économique générale la définition des
priorités stratégiques l'évolution du
secteur ou encore les questions de
souveraineté soulevées par l'explosion
des nouvelles technologies il est
pourtant impératif d'apporter une
réponse complète articulée entre les
priorités définies et les leviers à
actionner pour les atteindre les
interrogations sont nombreuses et les
défis de taille quand la valeur gén par
les réseaux en France s'écroule de près
de 46% en 10 ans comment investir dans
les infrastructures de demain dans la
virtualisation des réseaux ou encore
dans le cloud
nous sommes d'ailleurs étonnés face aux
menaces de sanctions pour non-respects
des engagements l3313 la zone a mis la
France est je le répète le pays le plus
fibré d'Europe il faut prendre le temps
de mesurer la prouesse industrielle et
technologique que cela représente en
seulement 5 ans entre 2017 et 2022 20
millions de locaux supplémentaires sont
devenus éligibles à la fibre c'est une
augmentation de 230% dans les
territoires les moins denses des réseaux
d'initiatives publiques 7 millions de
locaux supplémentaires sont devenus
éligibles à la fibre c'est une
augmentation de 717%. enfin depuis 2017
le Très Haut Débit compte 11 millions
d'abonnés supplémentaires pour atteindre
le chiffre de 17500 000 soit plus de la
moitié du nombre total d'abonnement à
Internet en France l'effort est
collectif nous le partageons avec tous
les acteurs de la filière néanmoins avec
un investissement de près de 9 milliards
d'euros et plus de 80% des prises
déployées entre 2011 et 2017 orange et
le principal artisan de ce succès c'est
aussi orange qui consciente sa place au
sein de la filière a décidé le seul et
sans contrepartie de financer les
surcoûts de ses partenaires liés aux
règles sanitaires en temps de covid nous
avons augmenté la rémunération à l'acte
de nos partenaires jusque 30% et
concéder des avances de trésorerie à
hauteur de 375 millions d'euros pour la
seule année 2020 ce choix a permis de
maintenir le rythme des déploiements au
pire de la crise et avec 6 millions de
prises FTTH déployées 2020 a même été
une année record nous aurions pourtant
pu faire un tout autre choix celui de
nous délier sur le plan juridique de nos
obligations réglementaires et de nos
engagements à la faveur de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire nous avons fait le
choix strictement inverse celui de
maintenir les déploiements quoi qu'il en
coûte aujourd'hui encore nous continuons
de protéger financièrement nos
partenaires en augmentant la
rémunération de ceux qui interviennent
sur les réseaux en considération de
l'inflation toutes ces raisons et ces
chiffres expliquent ma surprise
lorsqu'on m'a informé de menaces de nous
sanctionner pour des retards de
déploiement à léguer prenons le temps de
nous comparer à nos voisins en Allemagne
au Royaume-Uni la pénétration de la
fibre n'atteint pas 30% en France elle
est de plus de 80% même si nous étions
en retard sur nos engagements ce que
nous contestons de quelques dizaines de
milliers de prises seraient juste
raisonnable ou encore utile de
sanctionner l'opérateur qui a fait de la
France le pays le plus fibré d'Europe
qui a investit à hauteur de 9 milliards
d'euros qui a soutenu la filière pendant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire je tiens à
saluer particulièrement nos
techniciennes et nos techniciens qui ont
brillé et brillent encore par leur
courage et leur expertise au service du
plus grand nombre plutôt que perdre
notre temps à regarder dans le
rétroviseur je vous appelle à regarder
vers demain et à préparer ensemble
l'avenir bien sûr comment généraliser
l'accès au très haut débit d'ici 2025
comment garantir partout la qualité de
service y compris sur le réseau cuivre
historique encore essentiel à des
millions de Français
assurer l'universalité d'un accès très
haut débit avec une qualité de service
adéquate nécessite d'adresser dès
maintenant plusieurs chantiers
fondamentaux le reste à faire en termes
de déploiement FTTH et son fin la
fermeture du cuivre dans le calendrier
est adossé à celui de la généralisation
de la fibre cela implique aussi de
traiter financièrement la question de la
qualité de service sur le réseau cuivre
qui pour quelques années encore sera
celui sur lequel quelques millions de
nos concitoyens accéderont à l'Internet
fixe enfin cela implique de prendre des
mesures de facilitation de la migration
vers la fibre à 3 ans de l'échéance les
moyens nécessaires à la généralisation
de la fibre ne sont toujours pas
identifiées l'échéance du plan France
très haut débit c'est la fin de cette
année l'objectif d'un très haut débit
pour tous dont 80% en FTTH était clair
il est atteint l'objectif d'une
généralisation de la fibre optique les
beaucoup moins car nous savons toutes et
tous que cela ne peut vouloir dire 100%
de fibres sur le territoire donc nous
posons la question quel est l'objectif
et quels sont les mécanismes de
financement
généraliser la fibre optique implique de
définir et financer au moins deux outils
le premier pour adresser le financement
des raccordements dit complexes long
coûteux une première enveloppe de
subventionnement a été décidé début 2022
doté par l'état de 150 millions d'euros
seulement et à la condition d'engagement
des collectivités sur un même montant
alors même que seuls les rips sont
éligibles à cette enveloppe une
asymétrie de traitement que rien ne
justifie le taux de subventions par
local et de seulement 12,5% des coûts
éligibles pour un plafond moyen de 625
euros par local raccordable alors que
les coûts de raccordement sont en
l'espèce parfois supérieure à 5000 euros
aucun opérateur commercial ne raccordera
un client s'il doit supporter un tel
coup de raccordement et il est illusoire
d'imaginer les contraintes il est tout
aussi illusoire d'imaginer contraindre
l'opérateur d'infrastructures sur les
zones déployées sur fonds propres c'est
à dire pour 80% des locaux de
contraintes orange à subventionner les
opérateurs commerciaux
le deuxième outil est un guichet vers
lequel nos concitoyens au moins ceux
dont les revenus sont les plus faibles
pourrait se tourner pour obtenir une
aide financière quand des travaux de
génie civil sont nécessaires sur leur
terrain pour les raccorder à la fibre
c'est aussi une question d'abord
d'habilité du service universel ces
travaux ne sont pas réalisés par les
opérateurs et ils n'ont pas vocation à
l'être ce n'est pas seulement une
question de coût c'est surtout que ce
n'est pas le métier des techniciennes et
des techniciens ce guichet existe déjà
il s'agit du guichet cohésion numérique
nous recommandons de l'ouvrir aux
raccordement FTTH pour les cas où le
propriétaire doit prendre en charge des
frais de génie civil sur son terrain
à celles et ceux qui répètent qu'au
orange n'a qu'à payer et je sais qu'ils
ne sont pas dans cette émission
j'aimerais rappeler certains chiffres
c'est jamais mais
le marché européen des télécoms est
fragmenté et ultra concurrentiel on y
compte en effet plus de 100 opérateurs
sans opérateur quand on en dénombre
trois aux États-Unis et en Chine cela a
une conséquence directe sur les revenus
moyens par abonnés trois fois plus
faible en Europe 14 dollars aux
États-Unis où ils sont de 45 dollars le
contexte sectoriel en France est encore
plus difficile en disant sur un indice
sans en 2011 le prix des services
Telecom s'établit à 54 l'inflation à 108
les transports ferroviaires à 110
l'énergie à 141 en 2021 et les services
postaux à 156 le tarif moyen des offres
fixes s'établissaient en 2021 en France
à 22 euros contre 25 euros en Italie 31
en Espagne 35 au Royaume-Uni 45 en
Allemagne et 108 aux États-Unis
en outre orange se prépare à une
évolution majeure de business model
l'accélération de la transition du
cuivre vers la fibre entraîne à la fois
une baisse de nos revenus annuels sur le
marché de gros estimé à un milliard
d'euros après 2025 et une hausse de nos
coûts
par an pour la location du réseau fibre
dans les zones où nous ne sommes pas
opérateurs d'infrastructures dans ce
contexte avec ce trou d'air de 1,5
milliards d'euros par an dès 2025 nous
n'avons nous avons un autre défi à
adresser celui de la qualité de service
le défi principal la qualité de service
sur le réseau cuivre historique qui
constitue encore le seul moyen d'accès à
Internet de nombreux foyers il se vide
depuis 10 ans mais supporte encore 16,5
millions d'accès et subit des
dégradations en forte augmentation liées
entre autres à l'augmentation des aléas
climatiques ou au vol de câble je veux
dire ici avec force qu'on contraire de
ce que nous pouvons entendre parfois
orange n'abandonne pas le cuivre c'est
même tout le contraire nous continuons
d'investir et de consacrer à son
entretien et à sa maintenance près de
500 millions d'euros chaque année avec
le Premier ministre d'alors Jean Castex
nous avons bâti un plan d'action pour
améliorer sensiblement la qualité du
réseau et accompagner nos clients en cas
de panne l'ensemble des actions
annoncées par Orange ont été mises en
œuvre notamment la mise à disposition
sous 24 heures d'une solution
transitoire d'accès au réseau en cas de
dérangement d'une ligne principale le
maintien au catalogue des offres
héritées du service universel
téléphonique le recrutement de
techniciens supplémentaires le renforce
ciblé de la maintenance préventive et le
renforcement de la coopération au niveau
local nous devons aujourd'hui entretenir
deux réseaux filaires en parallèle ce
qui est intenable sur le long terme la
meilleure façon d'améliorer la qualité
de service du cuivre c'est donc de
fermer le réseau c'est pourquoi nous
avons présenté un plan de fermeture
ambitieux largement consultée et amendé
par toutes les parties prenantes son
calendrier est construit autour de
l'objectif de généralisation du FTTH en
2025 la première urgence et d'aligner le
cadre réglementaire avec le calendrier
de fermeture du cuivre la seconde
urgence c'est de traiter l'équation
économique du réseau cuivre je vais
tâcher d'être précise sur ce sujet car
il y a derrière cette équation de sujets
essentiel de la qualité de service du
cuivre encore primordial pour encore
quelques années la vétusté du réseau
commande que nous redoublions d'efforts
pour assurer sa maintenance les charges
d'exploitation du réseau cuivre son
entretien et sa maintenance sont
essentiellement des coûts fixes assurer
la qualité de service que nous devons à
nos clients et à nos concitoyens ces
mécaniquement augmenter le coût de
l'entretien et l'adole et de la
maintenance en fonction du nombre de
livres à la ligne active pourquoi
rapporter ses coûts à la ligne active
parce que seuls les lignes actives
rémunèrent aujourd'hui le réseau c'est
l'ARCEP qui décide de la rémunération du
réseau cuivre en décidant des tarifs
d'accès facturés aux opérateurs
commerciaux pour le dégroupage et le
génie civil la décroissance du parc
accélère il a baissé de 15% en 2021 et
cette tendance se confirme pour 2022 les
coups de maintenance eux ne baissent pas
proportionnellement ainsi en 4 ans de
2018 à 2021 le coût d'entretien à la
ligne cuivre a augmenté de 37 %. et
cette hausse va s'amplifier à mesure de
l'accélération de la bascule vers la
fibre c'est précisément à ce moment
charnière que l'ARCEP a décidé de
changer le modèle tarifaire
historiquement le modèle était celui de
l'orientation des tarifs vers les coûts
en 2020 l'arcecept a décidé de changer
le modèle pour déterminer tarifs
2021-2023 et test le bon moment la
question mérite d'être posée le nouveau
modèle tarifaire fondé sur la
modélisation d'un réseau FTTH théorique
comporte de plus des erreurs la
modélisation ne prend pas en compte tous
les éléments du réseau ce qui conduit
pour 2023 à une sous-évaluation du tarif
de 1,84 euros par mois s'ajoute à cela
une sous-évaluation de la fiscalité ce
que l'ARCEP semble maintenant connaître
cela conduit orange à régler une partie
de la fiscalité de ses concurrents
en outre en raison d'une incohérence de
calcul depuis début 2021 orange ne
recouvre plus la totalité de ses coups
de génie civil la non couverture des
coûts s'élève à 175 millions d'euros sur
la période 2021 2022 et s'élèvera à 79
millions d'euros en 2023 entre le
dégroupage et le génie civil si le
régulateur ne prend pas les décisions
qui s'imposent ce sont 228 millions
d'euros de recettes essentielles pour
maintenir l'infrastructure que nous ne
percevrons pas et qui resteront dans les
caisses des opérateurs commerciaux pour
vous donner une illustration concrète
cela correspond à accueillir
gratuitement l'un des trois grands
opérateurs commerciaux sur notre réseau
cette tendance nous l'observons dans les
indicateurs financiers la rentabilité
opérationnelle d'orange en France baisse
par exemple de 1% depuis 2018 alors que
celle de nos concurrents est en
croissance plus 2,9% pour Altice + 8,3%
pour Bouygues Telecom + 6,5 % pour
Iliade ce que je veux montrer ici c'est
que la régulation tarifaire par l'ARCEP
conduit à un transfert de valeur depuis
l'opérateur d'infrastructures vers les
opérateurs commerciaux mettant orange
dans une situation économique
inacceptable
ce qui se traduit aujourd'hui sur le
cuivre cela pourrait se produire demain
sur le FTTH il en irait alors de la
capacité des rips et donc des
collectivités à entretenir leur réseau
fin 2020 il y a eu un deal entre Orange
et la recette orange n'a pas attaqué la
décision de larcès en contrepartie d'un
accord pour revoir le tarif du
dégroupage dès lors qu'au orange aura
présenté un plan de fermeture du cuivre
concret et ambitieux nous avons tenu nos
engagements et demandons donc
naturellement que les tarifs du
dégroupage soit revu c'est ce qui avait
été convenu je refuse de croire que le
régulateur traite ce sujet avec lenteur
mais forcé de constater que le temps
passe que les coûts s'accumulent et
qu'un rebours de son engagement
vis-à-vis de nous l'Arcep n'a pas révisé
les tarifs d'accès pour 2022 et 2023
l'Arcep n'a rien fait alors que tout
était prévu et annoncé hausse des tarifs
de gros dans la précédente analyse de
marché si je vous dis tout cela c'est
parce que nous nous préparons à
introduire de lourds contentieux contre
les décisions de l'ARCEP de ne pas
revoir le tarif du dégroup
il ne s'agit pas de défendre une
prétendue rente il s'agit de défendre la
qualité de service à laquelle nos
concitoyens ont droit il s'agit aussi de
défendre l'emploi de rémunérer toute la
chaîne de valeur et notamment nos
partenaires qui interviennent sur le
réseau enfin il s'agit aussi de défendre
une politique publique de 40 de garantir
à toutes et à tous l'universalité d'un
accès très haut débit avec une qualité
de service adéquate par essence les
autorités administratives indépendantes
sont indépendantes mais elles sont
placées sous le contrôle du Parlement
elles ont des comptes à vous rendre
quand elles ont entre leurs mains une
partie de l'équation économique d'une
politique publique elle ne devrait pas
la capturer l'équation économique de
l'universalité de l'accès à un très haut
débit de qualité ne doit pas échapper au
Parlement avant d'approfondir ces
questions à la faveur des échanges
auxquels je vais maintenant laisser
place avant d'aborder les nombreux
sujets que je n'ai pas évoqué ici et ils
sont nombreux qu'il s'agisse de notre
empreinte environnementale de sobriété
énergétique des risques de délestage de
cybersécurité de le câble sous-marin de
nos innovations et bien d'autres sujets
encore je veux dire avec force qu'il est
grand temps que le politique prenne
toute sa place je vous rappelle notre
réalité et les nombreuses tensions sur
les infrastructures télécoms la filière
souffre de l'inflation le prix de la
matière première la fibre a été
multipliée par deux en Europe depuis le
début de cette année pénurie de sable le
coût de l'énergie a explosé les baux
sont indexés sur l'inflation les y faire
sont indexés sur l'inflation mais les
tarifs eux sur le gros comme au détail
ne sont pas indexés sur l'inflation la
structure des marchés ne permet pas à la
filière d'absorber les surcoûts auxquels
elle doit faire face ce qui n'est pas
sans impact en matière d'attractivité et
d'emplois il manque aujourd'hui sur le
marché 2000 techniciens d'intervention
qualifiés quand on parle de qualité des
interventions on doit aussi parler de
cela
voici le constat les réflexions que je
tenais à partager avec vous ce matin
soyons lucides la période que nous
traversons est compliquée et la route ne
sera pas toujours facile et nous sommes
riches d'une certitude la dimension
vitale de notre mission et la richesse
de notre collaboration nos réseaux sont
la colonne vertébrale de tous les
cosystème numérique et ce dernier
continuera de croître dans les années à
venir de façon exponentielle je veux
vous dire ma conviction que nous avons
toutes les clés en main pour prendre les
meilleures décisions et écrire ensemble
la suite du chemin je souhaite
m'inscrire avec toutes les parties
prenantes dans la construction d'une
vision ambitieuse et résolument
optimiste j'ai confiance dans notre
capacité collective à rénover notre
écosystème nous craignons pas de le
bousculer ça bouge en Europe le
commissaire Thierry Breton a une vive
conscience des lacunes institutionnels
et des asymétries réglementaires et des
États membres ont pris des décisions
structurantes pour favoriser
l'investissement des opérateurs
d'infrastructures pour accélérer les
déploiements de la fibre optique en
France aussi il y a beaucoup pas faire
pour adresser les défis de cette
décennie nous vont travailler et penser
différemment
moderniser une régulation en décalage
avec les évolutions du secteur la
priorité pour l'avenir ce sera le
financement des infrastructures je n'ai
aucun doute sur notre capacité à
l'adresses ensemble et vous et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour ne pas me
dérober je vous remercie
je crois qu'on avait compris la
médiatrice que vous ne vous dérobez pas
et je j'en profite pour vous dire que à
vous écouter on va programmer dans les
prochains jours une audition de la
recette assez rapidement voilà je vais
pas faire de commentaires
supplémentaires mais je vais laisser la
parole à notre collègue Patrick chaise
et je vous demande vous êtes beaucoup
d'inscrits donc il y a beaucoup de
d'intérêts autour de votre audition
comme d'habitude d'essayer d'être le
plus concis possible il y a 17 demandes
d'intervention voilà pour votre
information Patrick merci madame la
présidente Madame la Directrice Générale
Monsieur le Secrétaire général Monsieur
le Directeur des affaires publiques tout
d'abord bien sûr à vous remercier pour
votre propos et la clarté de celui-ci il
est précis et sans langue de bois
je voulais aussi vous rassurer le
politique en tout cas au Sénat ne
prendra toute sa place
j'ai bien sûr bien entendu votre
plaidoyer sur tous les côtés positifs du
déploiement et notamment la mise en
avant de notre pays en Europe et je
partage bien sûr ce positivisme
néanmoins parce qu'il y a toujours un
maire je voudrais revenir sur un certain
nombre de points en premier lieu vous
paraissez surprise des risques de
sanctueux de sanctions pardon qui
pourrait être prise par l'ARCEP
conséquence des engagements non tenus
par votre entreprise
je peux vous rejoindre
néanmoins pour dire que la temporalité
de ces menaces n'est pas la bonne même
si sur le fond je considère que il y a
quand même quelque chose à dire
en effet le secteur des
télécommunications et aujourd'hui
bousculé de toute part je peux lister la
qualité des raccordements la propriété
des infrastructures passives
résilience des réseaux la fiscalité
incontrôlée des outils de péréquation
inexistants le service universel en
sommeil la fin de la couverture à venir
le tarif du dégroupage controversé et
enfin le faire tcher
qui fait couler beaucoup d'encre en ce
moment et sur lequel nous aurons
beaucoup à travailler
ne croyez-vous pas qu'il serait temps
d'un New Deal ou good deal des réseaux
fixes car j'ai la conviction que pris
indépendamment des uns des autres tous
ces sujets sont insolubles
deuxième question sur l'extinction du
cuivre que pensez-vous de l'idée d'une
gouvernance dans laquelle les
collectivités gouvernent nationales dans
lesquelles les collectivités seraient
associées
troisième question il y a deux ans une
très grosse panne avait impacté les
appels d'urgence
avez-vous appris de cet événement et
pouvez-vous nous garantir qu'une telle
panne ne pourra se reproduire
troisième question
quatrième question pardon il y a qui
suivent les services de
télécommunication ne sont pas considérés
à priori comme prioritaire notamment par
rapport à l'alimentation en énergie
électrique que se passera-t-il en cas de
délestage sachant que notamment les
réseaux fibres sont dépendants de
l'énergie
vous l'avez dit remarqué madame
directrice générale je ne suis pas de
ceux qui pensent qu'au orange n'a qu'à
payer je suis par contre de ceux qui
pensent qu'au orange doit pouvoir jouer
un rôle déterminant dans le numérique en
France
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur votre
vision à terme de votre entreprise
et enfin vous avez émis plusieurs
interrogations voir critiques concernant
le régulateur
pensez-vous que le rôle de la recette
n'est pas en adéquation avec
l'écosystème ne faudrait-il pas réformer
son fonctionnement pour plus de
cohérence avec la politique
gouvernementale notamment par la
présence comme ça avait été émis par un
rapport du Sénat d'un commissaire du
gouvernement au sein de la recette
en tout cas quel serait vos suggestions
en la matière voilà même présidente plus
beaucoup de questions mais vous l'avez
remarqué avec
une concision forte parfait je vais
laisser répondre madame adiatrice
générale à Patrick et ensuite on prendra
l'ensemble des autres questions
merci alors monsieur le Président cher
Patrick chaise je vous remercie de
donner l'occasion par vos questions
d'approfondir certains des points que je
mettais en avant et en particulier le
les investissements que nous ont dans
nos réseaux
sur votre premier point concernant
finalement l'idée d'un New Deal fixe et
les enjeux de
de complétude on va dire où les
prochaines étapes
pour le pour le déploiement de notre
réseau
ce qui est sûr c'est que on peut faire
l'analogie avec le New Deal mobile que
nous avions fait
qui avait été construit en fait pour
adresser le sujet de la fracture
territoriale de la couverture mobile qui
avait bousculé effectivement le
paradigme des attributions de fréquence
en en faisant non plus un outil de
maximisation des recettes budgétaires de
l'État mais un outil de l'aménagement
numérique du territoire et 4 ans après
même s'il reste un peu de chemin on peut
reconnaître que le New Deal mobile a été
un programme qui a bien fonctionné que
l'on que l'on met en oeuvre quel
objectif pour un new DelFix je crois que
la généralisation de la fibre en 2025
devrait être l'objectif
lors de mes propos liminaires j'ai pu
partager avec vous le constat que fait
tout le secteur au-delà d'orange sur la
nécessité de créer de nouveaux outils de
financement pour faire de la Gigabit
Society une réalité je vous sais attaché
monsieur le Président à l'abondement
d'un fond d'aménagement numérique du
territoire il ne m'a pas échappé que le
Sénat a adopté un abonnement au projet
de loi de finance 2023 visant à
instaurer une taxe pied de page de 75
centimes par mois à la charge de nos
concitoyens les opérateurs commerciaux
seraient alors chargés de les collecter
de le collecter je crois qu'il n'est pas
tant d'augmenter la charge fiscale et
surtout pas la fiscalité sectorielle qui
pèse davantage que la fiscalité
d'entreprise à laquelle nous sommes
assujettis comme toute entreprise entre
la Toce la tstd les y faire etc ce sont
près de 1,5 milliards d'euros qui sont
ponctionnés sur les capacités
d'investissement des opérateurs pour
financer
l'audiovisuel public la création le CNC
et pour les y faire qui sont saupoudrés
entre les 3 commune interco et
départements c'est-à-dire tout sauf
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
c'est bien évidemment de ce côté-ci
qu'il faudrait regarder
regardons l'ifère fixe ce sont 400
millions d'euros par an collectés par
l'État et reversé aux communes et
départements c'est du saupoudrage alors
que 400 millions d'euros par an pour un
fond d'aménagement numérique du
territoire c'est l'assurance d'une fibre
généralisée en 2025
mais qui peut faire un tel deal les
collectivités uniquement c'est à elle
qu'appartiendrait d'initier un New Deal
fixe en décidant d'un fonds de
péréquation numérique du territoire
plutôt qu'un saupoudrage entre elles
toutes
donc effectivement le sujet d'un new
dealfix peut-être un sujet voilà nous
serions ravis d'y contribuer mais nous
ne sommes qu'un acteur qui ne pouvons
pas être en être à l'initiative sur le
votre question concernant la gouvernance
la gouvernance concernant le
décommissionnement du réseau du réseau
fixe c'est évidemment un sujet
absolument critique puisque ce projet ne
pourra aboutir et c'est un c'est un
chantier titanesque
ce projet ne pourra aboutir que dans un
cadre de confiance dans lequel chacun
jouera son rôle nous opérateurs
évidemment historique pilotant cette
infrastructure les pouvoirs publics le
régulateur et les collectivités locales
puisque nos clients les nos concitoyens
auront besoin d'un cadre de confiance
pour pouvoir y contribuer c'est
d'ailleurs tout l'esprit dans lequel
nous avons lancé le projet depuis le
début avec une volonté de dialogue fort
avec une démarche de pilote terrain et
on a beaucoup appris de nos échanges
justement sur le besoin d'inclure les
collectivités et donc les collectivités
ont absolument leur place le premier
nous avons défini aujourd'hui de l'eau
qui vont être les premiers pilotes sur
le décommissionnement du cuivre en
France avec une liste de communes qui a
été partagée et sur lequel nous allons
travailler main dans la main avec une
fois de plus le régulateur les
collectivités l'ensemble des opérateurs
puisque ce n'est pas que l'opérateur
d'infrastructures et bien sûr
et bien sûr le l'opérateur et l'ensemble
de nos clients donc vous avez
parfaitement raison sur l'importance de
l'engagement des collectivités dans ce
dans ce projet
et on a d'ailleurs fait une proposition
dans le sens où au gouvernement on me le
rappelle Nicolas Guérin la crise des
numéros d'urgence oui ça a été une crise
majeure pour l'entreprise alors à
l'époque j'en ai qu'administratrice de
cette entreprise et je peux vous assurer
que c'est quelque chose qui avait été
pris au plus haut niveau de l'entreprise
avec une enquête qui a été menée on en a
tiré de nombreuses conclusions que l'on
a mis en oeuvre sur la gestion de ce
type de ce type de crise qui
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire les
réseaux télécom le risque existera
toujours de panne dans les réseaux et
évidemment quand il s'agit de ce type de
service absolument critique c'est
quelque chose d'important donc on en a
tiré toutes les conséquences mais je
vais rebondir sur votre question
suivante le risque de délestage cet
hiver puisque malheureusement et vous
l'avez dit les réseaux télécoms ne sont
pas de par la loi concernant les sites
critiques qui a été défini en fait avant
l'arrivée des réseaux télécoms dans les
années 90
les sites Telecoms ne sont pas jugés
comme étant des sites prioritaires alors
en fait dans les dans les réseaux
télécoms il y a différents types de
sites et donc certains de nos sites sont
effectivement priorisées dans les plans
de prévention pour la préparation que
nous mettons en œuvre à des risques de
délestage mais une partie de nos sites
en particulier les dizaines de milliers
de sites mobiles et c'est un sujet que
nous adressons nous orange mais avec
l'ensemble de nos concurrents et avec la
Fédération des télécoms la dizaine de
milliers de sites mobiles ne sera pas
priorisé de même que nos clients et un
certain nombre de nos sites critiquent
dans le réseau qui sont équipées de
générateurs et de batterie ne seront pas
non plus priorisés donc il y a des
systèmes de secours qui permettront de
prendre le relais néanmoins si les
délaissages se multiplient on ne sait
pas en fait comment comportera le réseau
et ce que l'on appelle un site critique
dans les infrastructures télécoms ce
sont des sites
qui impacte et peuvent avoir un impact
au niveau national pour le réseau
puisqu'effectivement on parle de
délestage qui seront régionaux et on
s'organise on fait des exercices en
partenariat en partenariat et en bonne
entente j'allais dire entre opérateurs
avec le gouvernement et évidemment
enedis on a fait un certain nombre
d'exercices de crises c'est un sujet sur
lequel orange alerte orange et la
Fédération alerte le gouvernement depuis
le début de l'année 2022 en fait depuis
qu'on a été prévenus de risque de
délestage c'est un sujet sur lequel on
continue de travailler mais je crains
que nos concitoyens et les Français
découvrent que les réseaux télécom
dépendent d'électricité et qu'il est
absolument impossible car cela prendrait
plus de 5 ans
d'imaginer si tenter que ce soit
finançable et compatible avec nos
objectifs environnementaux également il
est illusoire d'imaginer mettre des
batteries au pied de chacun des sites
mobiles en France donc c'est
illusoire d'imaginer que en cas de les
stages on saura maintenir un service
continu pour l'ensemble des Français et
je rebondis sur votre point concernant
les numéros d'urgence puisque les
services mobiles si dans une zone
géographique ils sont éteints pendant
deux heures il n'y aura pas d'accès au
service des numéros d'urgence pendant un
temps alors on
il pourrait
il pourrait même y avoir et la
complexité de la communication que nous
préparons sur laquelle nous travaillons
évidemment puisque orange s'inscrire
s'inscrit en entreprise responsable donc
nous avons signé nous communiquerons sur
les risques de délestage nous sommes
engagés évidemment nous contribuons avec
notre plan de sobriété également nous
ferons de l'effacement sur notre réseau
pour essayer d'éviter ce type de
situation néanmoins forcer de constater
qu'il est de notre devoir de se préparer
une telle crise et qu'on devra
communiquer vers l'ensemble de nos
parties prenantes donc bien sûr les
collectivités nos partenaires le
gouvernement et puis bien sûr nos
clients chose que nous nous ferons mais
il pourrait y avoir des situations où
l'électricité la lumière fonctionne dans
un appartement mais les télécoms mobiles
ne fonctionnent pas parce que la tour
est dans une zone qui est elle-même
délestée ou vice-versa des zones où il
pourrait y avoir pas de lumière et voilà
donc ça va être des situations assez
inédites je peux vous assurer que
l'ensemble de nos techn soutien qui ont
l'habitude de gérer des crises suite à
des aléas climatiques seront sur le pont
pour faire en sorte que l'on que l'on
remette en service le plus rapidement
possible et en tout cas qu'on suive
notre notre priorité pour le moment et
de s'assurer qu'on travaille main dans
la main avec les opérateurs qui ont ces
informations pour anticiper puisque
chaque heure qui chaque heure que l'on
pourra anticiper d'informations et
aujourd'hui on aurait l'information de
risque de délestage que la veille vers
17 heures
et on essaie de faire en sorte de gagner
du temps puisque 24 heures d'information
supplémentaires ça nous permettrait à
nous d'avoir des techniciens sur le
terrain prêt à répondre et quelque part
de minimiser l'impact de tels risques
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
travaillons main dans la main bien sûr
avec le gouvernement bien sûr aussi avec
le régulateur la Fédération des télécoms
les opérateurs ont aussi fait des
propositions des listes de sujets que
l'on pourrait regarder pour voir comment
n'ont pas se préparer à adresser la
crise de cet hiver mais le prochain
hiver puisque l'hiver 2023 2024 ne sera
pas forcément plus simple d'un point de
vue énergétique voilà donc c'est c'est
des sujets sur lesquels on est
totalement mobilisé orange
a beaucoup plus j'allais dire de de
situations de secours et à une
résilience par nature de son réseau qui
est supérieur à celle de ses concurrents
parce que on y a beaucoup investi on
continue à investir mais il est
illusoire d'imaginer que s'il n'y a pas
d'électricité les réseaux continueront
de tourner sans impact pour nos clients
peut-être pour revenir sur vos votre
point concernant évidemment ma vision
pour le rôle d'orange et donc c'est
quelque chose sur lequel je travaille
main dans la main avec l'ensemble des
équipes depuis maintenant un peu plus de
6 mois nous sommes engagés à communiquer
au marché financier au mois de février
le 16 février très très précisément
notre feuille de route financière et
stratégique je suis convaincu de
plusieurs choses d'une part orange à des
atouts indéniables quand je disais qu'au
orange est l'un des trois opérateurs
historiques qui est néanmoins leader au
niveau mondial on est alors plus dans le
top 10 mais 11e au niveau mondial c'est
loin d'être le cas de tous les
opérateurs historiques européens on a
des atouts puisqu'on a un vesti
massivement dans la fibre bien avant
certains de nos concurrents européens on
a évidemment des atouts puisque orange
c'est internationalisé et donc on est
très très fier de la croissance de nos
activités et du service que l'on apporte
dans de nombreux pays en Europe et en
Afrique et au troisième trimestre c'est
c'est bien les zones hors France
l'Europe et l'Afrique qui a tiré la
croissance du groupe donc on a de
nombreux atouts et notre plus fort à
tous si je puis dire c'est d'une part la
qualité de nos experts et je l'entends
de partout alors bien sûr en interne de
l'entreprise mais toutes les personnes
avec qui je travaille et j'échange que
ce soit des concurrents que ce soit des
partenaires reconnaissent la grande
expertise des collaborateurs d'orange et
puis j'ai envie de dire orange n'est
jamais aussi fort que quand il est
mobilisé sur des projets ambitieux
orange a montré par le passé qu'il
savait que l'entreprise savait affronter
des défis et se transformer et nous
continuerons à le faire et je suis
convaincu qu'à un moment où finalement
les services rendus par Orange à ses
clients sont absolument critiques et
indispensables la crise covid n'a fait
qu'accélérer des tendances de fond il
est de notre responsabilité de renforcer
de continuer à innover pour apporter
toujours toujours un meilleur service et
un service qui peut encore être enrichi
puisqu'il y a énormément d'innovations à
apporter à nos clients grand public
comme entreprise et que la qualité des
infrastructures d'orange est un vrai axe
de différenciation pour nous j'ai parlé
de la fibre mais je pourrais parler des
câbles sous-marins ou d'autres activités
qui sont évidemment une de nos forces et
tout cela dans un contexte où je pense
aussi que la politique européenne ou en
France mais avant tout européenne doit
prendre conscience et doit changer un
certain nombre de choses pour que nous
ne délétions pas les investissements
dans les infrastructures en Europe et
que nous ne nous réveillons pas dans
quelques années en nous disant que nous
avons laissé partir la valeur dans un
contexte où la souveraineté n'a jamais
fait autant partie des débats et qu'il y
a une vraie prise de conscience
collective mais c'est vrai que ce sont
des sujets sur lesquels nous en sommes
convaincus chez Orange l'ensemble des
opérateurs en Europe parce que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel les grands
opérateurs européens sont tous
convaincus et même dans certaines
d'autres continents ce sont des sujets
sur lesquels nous travaillons donc
rendez-vous en février mais je peux vous
assurer que je suis convaincu qu'au
orange à absolument de nombreux atouts
pour retrouver cet esprit de conquête
qui a été celui d'Orange et de France
Télécom avant très bien merci beaucoup
on va attaquer le le tunnel on va on va
je reviendra enfin je pense qu'il y aura
d'autres questions on va revenir
on va attaquer le tunnel des questions
par Franck mais Nonville puis ensuite
Fabien gay merci madame la présidente
Madame la Directrice générale tout
d'abord vous remercier pour la clarté de
vos propos qui ont été déjà extrêmement
complets moi je voudrais vous interroger
sur le déploiement de la 5G et notamment
en lien avec les tendances actuelles de
hausse de l'énergie la flambée des
énergies donc bien évidemment d'épargne
pas le secteur des télécom et donc en
s'appuyant sur cette sur cette
problématique actuelle il pourrait cela
pourrait entraîner
le ralentissement du rythme de la
déploiement de la 5G et notamment dans
les territoires ruraux je rappelle qu'il
était prévu environ 10 500 antennes
répartis par opérateur sur l'ensemble du
territoire dont 20 25 % dans les
territoires ruraux on nous dit et on
commence à
entendre parler d'un ralentissement
possible pourriez-vous nous rassurer
parce que la 5G dans le dans les
territoires ruraux c'était à la fois un
outil d'aménagement du territoire mais
aussi de capacité à accueillir à
développer l'économie donc c'est
absolument essentiel et la deuxième
question vous l'avez effleuré c'est les
câbles sous-marins et dans cette
dynamique actuelle enfin dynamique dans
ces tensions géopolitiques actuelles et
de risque que nous nous pouvons
entrevoir quelle mesure prenez-vous pour
pour
prévoir ce risque émergent
merci Franck pas bien gay ensuite
Jean-Claude Tissot bonjour Madame la
Directrice générale je vous remercie
pour vos propos là aussi introductifs je
pense qu'on pourrait se rejoindre sur le
rôle de l'ARCEP
et puis je vous ai bien écouté vous avez
salué deux fois vos collaborateurs les
opérateurs je vous racontais un tout
petit histoire en une minute moi on va
on va bientôt fêter nos deux ans puisque
je suis client chez Orange depuis deux
ans
à la sortie du confinement comme tout le
monde j'ai eu besoin de beaucoup
d'Internet et dans ma rue à Blanc-Mesnil
la fibre a été posée par par Orange
juste avant j'avais pas eu le temps de
de m'abonner je l'ai fait 31 31 janvier
en 3 minutes j'ai souscrit l'offre super
ça a été plus compliqué avec votre
concurrent pour résilier mais en 3
minutes sur Internet impeccable on m'a
envoyé plusieurs textos j'ai vu des gens
pour m'invertir que l'opérateur allait
venir installer les choses on m'a même
envoyé un texto pour me donner le nom du
technicien à 21h et en me disant que si
j'avais des questions à lui poser je
pouvais le faire je me suis ils doivent
être bien payé orange parce que pour
bosser à 21h à être le lendemain chez
moi à 8h bon j'avais pas de question il
arrive
franchement super non mais
voilà non non mais moi évidemment je
discute avec lui vous savez bon alors je
dis mais vous êtes embauché chez Orange
pas du tout oh il n'osait pas trop je
dis mais allez-y vous savez moi comme ça
je suis personne vous pouvez y aller
il dit non non je suis un sous-traitant
ah bon ah oui même monsieur je me plains
pas alors j'ai parce que il y a pire que
nous avons pire que de sous-traitant oui
oui on sous-traite
les les cas les plus difficiles pour
vous c'était un cas identifié facile le
câble était juste attiré avec le poteau
en face mais ce où ils sont ils sont
galères on les donne à notre
sous-traitant et eux ils sont pas payés
à la journée ils sont payés à la pièce
donc quand je veux dire ça pourquoi
c'est qu'à un moment donné chaque fois
que un libéral me parle dans les
télécommunications c'est formidable la
libéralisation sans prêt à baiser
marcher oui mais à quelle condition
aussi de destruction d'emplois et alors
je vous passe le détail d'une personne
qui est venue sonner à mon portail trois
heures après je me faisait qui ah mais
moi je suis un sous-traitant embauché
par le sous-traitant d'orange pour
vérifier que tout allait bien bon mais
tout va bien et même le soir j'ai reçu
un texto pour évaluer comme uber si le
salarié était bien voyons rentre dans
quelque chose moi j'ai pas évalué les
hommes et les femmes sur une application
et je vous passe en deux secondes je
viens je veux un problème Internet le 10
alors là pour avoir le service client
complexe ça a duré trois mois
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ben un moment
donné un technicien est venu il y avait
en fait un arrachage des câbles dans le
boîtier dans la rue à 1 km 570 puisque
le monsieur est venu brancher impeccable
mais c'est aussi ça la sous-traitance
c'est que comme les gens sont payés à la
pièce mais quand ils viennent brancher
il s'en foutent du travail bien fait il
faut aller vite et donc ils arrachent
parfois les autres clients il se branche
et nos collectivités elles sont aussi
face à ça et et les clients et les
usagers je vais dire usagers parce que
madame la Présidente a dit usager très
bien je me conforme à ça les usagers des
communications ils subissent aussi ça
voilà c'était une petite histoire la
libéralisation de ça aussi ses
conséquences là sur la question de
l'emploi et bon le prix il est quand
même costaud pour avoir un service de
qualité je reconnais le téléphonie
Internet et télévision voilà je vous
remercie merci Fabien de cette petite
histoire du matin
très illustratrice
Jean-Claude Tissot ensuite à Mel merci
madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice Générale j'avais plusieurs
questions mais vous avez déjà répondu à
travers les questions de mes collègues
qui ont déjà été posées j'en ai quand
même malgré tout trois une qui qui
s'agit enfin donc fabien a abordé un
sujet c'est les sous-traitants
entre autres la problématique que vous
avez pu rencontrer avec la coopérative
Scopelec qui est aujourd'hui en
redressement judiciaire suite à la perte
de plusieurs contrats de sous-traitance
auprès d'Orange et il m'a donné
directrice alors que ce sujet semble
être l'une de vos principales priorités
lors de votre arrivée à la tête du
groupe Orange que pouvez-vous nous dire
aujourd'hui sur la poursuite des
contrats de sous-traitance restant avec
le groupe Scopelec constatez-vous
des impacts sur la pose de la fibre et
l'entretien du réseau cuivre à la suite
de ces récents événements j'avais un mot
aussi sur le délestage alors j'ai appris
que c'est que la veille vous allez
savoir où est-ce que ça allait être
délesté faut juste avoir gardé en
mémoire certes les numéros d'urgence
mais il y a tous les gens qui
télétravail donc si en allumant
l'ordinateur le matin à 8h il se rendent
compte qu'ils sont délestés qu'est-ce
qu'ils font
voilà donc c'est une question qui qui
méritait d'être soulignée je
souhaiterais aborder la question des
zones blanches et la gestion des
personnes électrosensibles alors ça
paraît peut-être en exotique mais le
maillage en réseau le maillage en réseau
de l'ensemble du territoire doit bien
sûr être une priorité et je suis un
fervent défenseur de de ce système là
notamment pour diminuer les inégalités
d'accès au numérique entre les
territoires ruraux et urbains toutefois
face à ce logique accroissement des
réseaux qui sera renforcé par la 5G les
personnes électrosensibles ont de plus
en plus de difficultés pour trouver des
espaces vivables pour eux et cette
problématique particulière se pose
notamment dans mon département donc
Madame la Directrice comment rendez-vous
en compte cet enjeu dans vos stratégies
d'implantation et de développement du
réseau avez-vous des protocoles adaptés
pour accompagner ces personnes c'est une
vraie vraie problématique et puis pour
terminer vous l'avez dit dans vos propos
alors ils ont 2030 vous allez devoir
déposer le réseau cuivre vous mais le
déposer physiquement c'est à dire vous
allez enlever le cuivre de
depuis qu'ils sont sur les poteaux et ma
question est très simple et j'ai posé la
question aux responsable
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes qui est venu me
voir en permanence la semaine dernière
où il y a 15 jours
quid de la maintenance des poteaux
bois alu sur nos territoires le bord de
route quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui avec
un fil cuivre sur ces 10 poteaux sont
déjà très très mal entretenues très très
mal changé quand ils sont cassés donc
voilà ce que vous allez passer des
contre-atts des conventions avec avec
les opérateurs est-ce que vous avez une
réponse à nous apporter pour nous
rassurer merci Madame
la présidente Madame la Directrice
Générale donc plusieurs questions ont
déjà été posées celle-ci celle-ci je
vais la garder elle porte sur le marché
des entreprises notamment vos réponses à
leurs exigences et à leur nécessaire
évolution question qui d'ailleurs
pourrait concerner également le marché
des collectivités aujourd'hui on assiste
donc à une prise de conscience à des
entreprises concernant le lieu
d'hébergement et les règles de
sauvegarde des données et plus
précisément de leur double sauvegarde
nous avons tous en tête l'incendie
survenue notamment dans le bâtiment
d'OVH à Strasbourg autre sujet
d'importance pour les entreprises
petites et moyennes d'ailleurs le
renouveau de la téléphonie via notamment
la montée en puissance du télétravail
grâce aux outils de Visio aux outils
collaboratifs accélérés par la crise
sanitaire donc outils qui
aujourd'hui donc remplace les échanges
téléphoniques standards vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure même en One to One il a
concevable de connecter son entreprise
et ses collaborateurs à Internet sans
prendre en compte les questions de
sécurité
informatique donc comme vous l'avez
compris je parle ici notamment donc de
la dématérialisation des télécoms et de
la montée en puissance du cloud vous
avez évoqué les conséquences économiques
de ces évolutions et la difficile
équation justement qui se présente à
vous puisque vous portez l'essentiel en
fait des investissements nécessaires
pour ces évolutions là donc ma question
est la suivante quelle est la vision
d'orange sur ces sujets donc sont le
Cloud et la sécurité quelles réponses
quelle stratégie comptez-vous
entreprendre je vous remercie merci
beaucoup Amel Bernard buis ensuite
Martine Berthet merci Président Madame
la Directrice Générale ma question porte
sur l'entretien des réseaux fixes en
drop mais je pense qu'on n'est pas
département isolé de nombreux files
traînent par terre de nombreux poteaux
tiennent par les fils et très souvent
des personnes qui sont dans des habitats
un peu éloignés se retrouvent en panne
quelquefois avec de la téléassistance
qui ne fonctionne pas pendant trois mois
voire 6 mois pour certains donc ça
commence à poser beaucoup de problèmes
les personnes nous interroge quelquefois
en intervenant auprès des personnes
localement on arrive à avoir une
intervention qui se fait rapidement des
engagements avaient été pris puisque
votre prédécesseur était venu dans la
Drôme avec Monsieur Castex et donc un
suivi était mis en place en préfecture
ça fait un an qu'on a plus de comité de
suivi et on a l'impression que ça a été
mis un peu en sommeil alors en même
temps on a des difficultés de
branchement récurrentes moi je ferai un
peu comme Fabien et je vais vous décrire
notre cas particulier j'ai changé de
permanence changer de ville j'ai signalé
cela orange au mois de juillet on nous a
dit dans un premier temps qu'on
garderait le même numéro de téléphone
même quand changer de ville au mois de
septembre on nous a dit que c'était pas
possible qu'on changerait le numéro on
nous attribue à numéro on a déménagé au
1er novembre comme prévu c'était
exactement le 28 octobre tout ce qui
était fibre a très bien fonctionné
l'Internet a fonctionné dès le premier
jour aujourd'hui 30 novembre on est
toujours son téléphone
voilà donc ça a été compliqué je vous
dis pas le nombre d'interlocuteurs de
personnes qui sont venues on a envoyé
des photos on prenait la place d'une
personne qui était là dans les locaux
précédemment on nous a dit on va vous
faire un PLP donc j'ai découvert ce que
c'était prendre la place en même temps
ça m'a ouvert un peu les yeux sur ce qui
se passait dans certaines communes et
dans l'habitat reculé où je suis ou
quelquefois réparateur via réparer un et
couper la place quelqu'un d'autre trois
semaines après l'autre personne qui
arrive elle n'a plus de téléphone donc
normalement si tout va bien demain on
devrait avoir le téléphone installé
alors qu'on est en plein centre-ville à
Valence c'est un peu bizarre
ça va être le miracle de l'audition
Martine Berthet ensuite Jean-Marc Boyer
merci madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice Générale merci beaucoup pour
vos propos front et clair je vais
revenir sur le délestage électrique donc
vous nous dites la veille à 17h et les
10 nous dit 21h ça fait quand même une
différence pour pouvoir s'organiser le
lendemain qu'en est-il est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser allez vous prévenir vos
clients qu'en est-il des services
d'urgence puisque vous relèvent vont
tenir un certain temps mais très peu de
temps visiblement il y a une
expérimentation qui se fait alors je ne
sais pas si c'est que dans mon
département ou si ça existe d'ailleurs
avec des des véhicules des VSAB avec le
10 connectés qui permettent de répondre
à ces questions de coupures de fin de
perte de connexion est-ce que cela se
déploie ailleurs quel est le rythme
comment cela va-t-il évoluer merci
Martine Jean-Marc Boyer ensuite
Dominique Estrosi Sassone
oui merci
madame la Présidente pour votre
exposé qui était très complet moi je
vous interroger sur la transition entre
le cuivre et la fibre comment orange va
permettre aux utilisateurs un passage
pour tous je dirais en douceur et éviter
les démarches frauduleuses qui
commencent à pointer et associer au
mieux les collectivités dans leurs
besoins
ce qui aurait pas de la nécessité d'une
communication nationale qui pourrait
être mise en place comme pour la TNT par
exemple
les mairies des collectivités ont besoin
pour des abonnements multi sites en
particulier des écoles des services
techniques et des mairies comment les
choses peuvent s'organiser et enfin le
problème de la fibre en souterrain pour
les communes qui ont fait déjà beaucoup
d'efforts de mise en souterrain
des
électricité et téléphone et à les
remettre des poteaux dans la campagne
pour mettre la fibre c'est quand même
problématique parce qu'apparemment
apparemment on ne peut pas passer la
fibre dans les mêmes fourreaux que ont
pu se pomper les conduits électricité et
téléphone
loisirs merci madame la présidente
Madame la Directrice générale le marché
de la cybersécurité est en plein boom
dans le sillage d'augmentation continue
des attaques informatiques à l'égard des
particuliers comme des entreprises donc
je souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
stratégie d'orange en matière de de
cybersécurité et au travers plus
particulièrement de votre filiale Orange
cyber défense l'ex patron d'Orange avait
envisagé de côté orange cyber défense en
bourse qu'en est-il aujourd'hui et dans
le domaine de la cybersécurité c'est des
grands groupes sont préoccupés par cette
menace mais si intéressent de fait
depuis plusieurs années et qu'il dispose
quand même de boutiques qui semblent
efficaces en tout cas pour se protéger
il n'en est pas de même des petites et
des très petites et moyennes entreprises
est-ce que vous entendez vous proposer
une protection
plus particulière à destination des TPE
et PME
redon-sarzy merci Madame la présente
Madame la directrice et merci surtout de
vous éclairage qui viennent nous
indiquer un peu non en tout cas nous
mettre orientés nos réflexions 3
réflexions donc générale d'abord tout à
l'heure quand vous avez parlé de la
fiscalité et du saupoudrage aux
collectivités moi je voudrais bien
savoir quels sont les éléments qui vous
permettent concrets de le dire et je
pense que soutenir les finances de nos
collectivités pour aménager et
entretenir par exemple l'accès au réseau
c'est pas forcément c'est du saupoudrage
bienvenue
s'agissant des câbles sous-marins vous
avez évoqué rapidement quelles
perspective pour votre groupe et surtout
quelle vulnérabilité au vu de
l'actualité sur d'autres d'autres sujets
mais voilà qui pourraient se rejoindre
quel engagement de votre part sur le
volet satellitaire sur le grand projet
aussi de constellation de satellite
sachant que nous avons déjà en France
plusieurs milliers d'abonnés en ligne
donc voilà comment allons-nous réagir
sur le volet du transfert de valeur que
vous avez évoqué entre les opérateurs de
réseau et les opérateurs commissions je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet de
réflexion de notre part comment faire
contribuer ce effectivement qui
sollicite sur sollicite les surréaux
mais aussi ça pose un certain nombre de
questions en terme d'impact
environnemental du numérique et je pense
que vraiment il faudra qu'on revienne
sur ce sujet trois petites questions
techniques très rapides le déploiement
aérien qui a déjà été évoqué par nos
collègues et déploiement à rien du
réseau fibre nous sommes parfois
effectivement inquiets sur les
vulnérabilités dans ces temps de d'aller
acclimatiques de tempête et autres donc
derrière quelle vulnérabilité quel
entretient quelle garantit avant nous
sur les comités cuivre dans les
départements ils participaient vous
comment comment est-ce que cela se passe
et plus globalement sur les objectifs
cuisent vendez-vous en fait vos vos
cuivres suite
très du réseau à qui les vendez-vous en
termes de souveraineté c'est intéressant
qui soit plutôt qui reste plutôt en
France
et ces recettes à quoi servent-ils à
quoi servent-elles en fait est-ce
qu'elles peuvent intervenir dans le
cadre des raccordements complexes qui
sont sous votre responsabilité merci
merci Anne-Catherine Christian Redon
Sarrasi ensuite Évelyne Renaud
Garabedian oui merci
Madame la Directrice générale vous avez
parlé de souveraineté tout à l'heure le
désengagement des opérateurs télécoms
des tours et des infrastructures
terrestres pose question en termes de
souveraineté alors que l'actualité de
cesse de démontrer l'importance du
numérique et que les télécoms sont
classés opérateurs d'importance vitale
mais qu'ils peuvent céder à loisir leurs
actifs à des investisseurs étrangers
outre que ces actifs ne seront plus
gérés par les opérateurs ils sont
massivement utilisés par les grandes
plateformes on sait tous qu'en fin de
journée le trafic YouTube et Netflix
c'est 70% du trafic Internet sans que
ces plateformes ne révélèrent les
opérateurs alors qu'elle facture au
service de plus en plus cher alors
s'abonnés d'un côté les opérateurs
doivent toujours investir dans leur
réseau pour les moderniser et verser les
loyers toujours plus élevés assez Tower
co du fait de la densification des
installations car en effet il faut de
plus en plus d'antenne pour aborder un
trafic en croissance permanente de
l'autre il ne parviennent pas à
valoriser leur service les opérateurs
télécoms craignent de devenir donc de
simples gestionnaires de tuyaux alors
qu'il ne possèderont même plus ses
tuyaux donc on peut donc légitimement
s'interroger sur la perte de
souveraineté qu'entraîne la session et
la mutualisation de ces infrastructures
quelles sont les mesures de protection
que vous envisagez donc à moyen terme et
à long terme afin que les opérateurs qui
vont ne soient pas petit à petit
rachetés et ne deviennent pas de simples
gestionnaires de réseau qu'il ne
posséderont plus
merci Christian
Évelyne pardon Renaud
oui Madame le Directeur Général j'aurais
deux questions à vous poser l'une sur
l'expatriation et l'autre sur
l'innovation numérique en Afrique le
groupe Orange compte comme vous l'avez
vu tout à l'heure plus de 140 000
collaborateurs dans le monde donc 40 %
en dehors de la France et vous faites
partie des groupes mondiaux qui
attachent une importance particulière à
l'expatrier en tant que sénateur des
Français de l'étranger je me préoccupe
de l'intégration de ce va plutôt de
celle qui suivent les conjoints
expatriés et qui deviennent des suiveurs
et qui se voit proposer un poste à
l'étranger orange et signataire d'une
convention qui est relative au conjoint
salarié des expatriés et lorsque les
deux employeurs du couple sont
signataires de cette même convention le
conjoint suiveur peut bénéficier d'une
suspension de son contrat de travail en
France jusqu'à son retour en France cela
lui ouvre le droit pendant une durée de
cinq années maximum durant laquelle il
peut exercer dans le pays de
l'expatriation de son mari un poste de
salarié et je voudrais savoir si vous
avez des données sur le succès de ces
mesures qui sont destinées à aider les
conjoints des expatriés la deuxième
question porte sur l'innovation
numérique en Afrique vous réalisez 6,4
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en Afrique et au Moyen-Orient et je
voulais savoir si au-delà des activités
téléphoniques
traditionnel de votre groupe quelle
place présent l'activité dans
l'accompagnement et l'innovation
numérique en Afrique merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame et
demain pour la force et la clarté de
votre présentation des problématiques de
votre entreprise par moment j'avais
l'impression que vous parliez des
déboires aussi def moi je considère que
comme pour EDF l'État français et les
gouvernements successifs qui le dirigent
contribue à l'affaiblissement
méthodique
de ces grandes entreprises publiques
historiques qui gêne dans le paysage de
la concurrence libre et non faussée mais
qui pour moi doivent être le socle du
développement d'un service public
moderne construit sur le principe de
l'accès universel que vous avez rappelé
plusieurs fois et je vous en remercie
une structure de tarif adapté à ce
modèle de service public universel
permettrait de répondre à l'enjeu du
modèle économique équilibré
indispensable que vous appelez de vos
vœux
par parallélisme des formes avec les
réseaux d'énergie
une structuration
en trois en trois points accès au réseau
contribution aux charges de services
publics et prix de la bande de passants
ou de la donnée a-t-elle votre faveur et
sinon sur quel principe de structuration
envisagez-vous donc la rémunération
finalement de l'entreprise orange pour
qu'elle retrouve dans la durée un modèle
économique équilibré je vous remercie
Rémi Cardon ensuite Daniel salmon merci
madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice Générale j'aimerais vous
poser une question
sans revenir sur les histoires de
sous-traitants plutôt me focaliser sur
la cyber la sécurité
j'ai on a conçu avec avec quelques
sénateurs de la délégation des
entreprises un rapport sur la
cybersécurité notamment des TPE PME sur
lequel on a quelques mois déjà on
s'alertait de la difficulté et j'ai bien
compris j'ai bien suivi votre actualité
vous aussi apparemment ma question est
la suivante c'est quel est votre feuille
de route derrière tout ça quand je vois
que au final vous allez certainement
vous recentrer sur la partie Télécom et
la partie cyber sécurité suite à
peut-être même à des inaugurations de de
il y a quelques mois à Toulouse
notamment vers défense ou d'autres le
recrutement je vois que ça s'accélère
aussi mais concrètement puisqu'on nous
on avait récupérer la difficulté entre
l'annecy qui accompagne les eiv et
cyber malveillance qui accompagne le
reste j'ai envie de vous dire comment
vous vous allez vous positionner avec
peut-être une offre packagée c'est ce
qu'on préconisé en tout cas dans le
rapport pour les TPE PME enfin comment
vous allez vous emparer du sujet sachant
que j'ai bien compris que l'objectif
était d'avoir un milliard de de chiffre
d'affaires en 2023 en ayant fait
l'acquisition de deux entreprises
suisses voilà je voulais avoir un peu
votre état d'esprit sur la feuille de
route pour la suite et ça vient en
complément de la question de tout à
l'heure de ma collègue merci Jérémy
Daniel salmon suite Daniel Gremillet
merci madame la Présidente
le numérique pèse aujourd'hui 1600
millions de tonnes de CO2 soit 4 fois
l'empreinte de la France comment
travailler vous pour réduire cette
empreinte sachant que votre Directeur de
l'innovation minimise largement cet
impact autre question pouvez-vous nous
donner des éléments sur le flex Office
qui vise à réduire les espaces de
travail avec un taux de 0,6 permettent
le télétravail nous semble bien entendu
vertueux mais l'imposer massivement pose
question et il génère un mal-être chez
certains de vos salariés
pouvez-vous nous donner également
quelques éléments sur la 6G voir la 7g
puisque elles sont déjà à l'étude
c'est ce que l'on m'a dit toujours mais
vous allez confirmer ou infirmer
vous le savez la 5G se déploie
aujourd'hui vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de d'explosion des nouvelles
technologies en même temps que ces
nouvelles technologies explosent les il
y a également une explosion des troubles
du comportement est-ce que vous
travaillez cela dans le cadre de votre
RSE sachant que quelque part vous vendez
du temps d'écran et que cela n'est pas
sans poser question dernière chose la
masse salariale de de Orange a augmenté
de 3%
pouvez-vous nous dire un peu comment se
répartissent cette masse salariale merci
merci Daniel Daniel Grémillet et ensuite
Daphné rakmadou oui merci Madame
présidente Madame la Directrice Générale
merci première remarque concernant le
délestage on sait que ce délestage va
être par zone mais la conséquence je
vais rester que sur le domaine
industriel
c'est que même une zone qui n'est pas
délestée dès lors qu'elle n'est plus en
lien par avec le site principal qui est
lui délester tout s'arrête
donc je veux pas rajouter parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps mais je suis très
surpris que vous ne fassiez pas partie
des prioritaires parce que la
conséquence c'est en cascade c'est
l'effet domino donc je le dis je vais
pas rajouter mais
on est en commission des affaires
économiques ici on n'a pas mesuré les
conséquences les phénominaux je parle en
connaissance de cause
étant un peu concerné sur le
fonctionnement et tous les industriels
aujourd'hui sont dans ce schéma là
alors c'est pas une question c'est de
remarque
je fais partie du Grand Est je trouve
que vous avez été un peu timide quand
même sur les investissements des
collectivités
et que à travers la France si la région
Grand Est départements s'il est comme
enfin les EPCI n'avaient pas investi le
retard dans lequel on est aujourd'hui on
est serait encore plus grand et surtout
les zones rurales et ça me fait repenser
au défi de l'électrification si les
collectivités n'avaient pas été là et
aujourd'hui en France tout le monde est
alimenté le débat de la communication et
du même niveau donc je le dis et je
termine par une question sur cet aspect
là
est-ce que l'aspect le
développement la communication
satellitaire est quelque chose que la
France ne regarde pas je veux pas
rajouter sur la question de la 5 6 7
mais c'est une question que je pose
parce que vous le regardez est-ce que
vous expertisez et ma dernière question
sur la téléphonie on fait partie avec
par les préfets on est convoqué aux
commissions départementales mais par
définition sénateur il se déplacent
beaucoup sur les territoires et plus on
a le relais et moins ça marche ma
question elle est simple est-ce qu'on a
diminué la puissance des relais parce
que ça serment la téléphonie se dégrade
sur nos territoires et on n'arrête pas
de rajouter des relais et c'est pas un
phénomène uniquement dans le grand test
c'est
un constat national donc je voudrais
bien savoir pourquoi
je voulais revenir sur le sujet évoqué
par famille gay de l'arrachage dans les
armoires notamment ça a poussé certains
mers et que c'est un cadenasser
notamment leurs armoires et à permettre
aux techniciens de venir par exemple à
la police municipale en s'inscrivant
pour avoir accès aux armoires et ce
système qui est une espèce de police pas
très légale à épeler aussi par les
intervenants parce qu'en fait ça ça
permet de réguler justement ce phénomène
d'arrachage et ça induit en fait un une
question sur les moyens et les délais
mise en qui vont pouvoir être mises en
oeuvre pour la mise à jour de la
cartographie en fait des branchements en
temps réel puisque ça il y a un problème
en fait de mise à jour de cette
cartographie et ce qui en cascade c'est
source d'erreurs et ça augmente plus on
va avancer en fait plus les
un nouveau branchements vont être rendus
difficile et une autre question sur
les éléments induits par la séparation
entre la partie réseau et la partie
commerciale on est confronté un cas sur
un petit peu de l'ordinaire de
branchement par le manque de technicité
en fait des agents commerciaux
qui fait qu'entre la partie qui sont pas
en capacité de répondre à des problèmes
de branchement un petit peu qui sortent
de l'ordinaire et ça implique des délais
assez énormes après en cascade entre la
partie réseau et la partie commerciale
et donc voilà comment est-ce que vous
pensez régler ces questions merci Daphné
une dernière intervention de Françoise
Ferrat
oui merci madame la Présidente une
remarque je rejoins les collègues qui
ont partagé les difficultés qu'il
rencontre sur le terrain en zone rurale
très profonde c'est particulièrement
compliqué et on coupe facilement dans un
dans un regard pour alimenter une
habitation détriment d'une autre je ne
reviens pas dessus tout a été dit sur ce
sujet la question qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est en complément de celle de
Daniel grimillet qui évoquait cette
multiplicité de poteaux
d'antenne ici et là quid de l'itinérance
qui avait été une obligation il y a
quelques années est-ce qu'elle est
toujours d'actualité et elle obligeait
et c'était à mon avis une très bonne
idée plusieurs opérateurs à s'installer
sur le même pylône et pour le fait et de
ce fait c'était quand même un peu plus
intéressant en terme de paysages
mes petits Françoise je profite pour
remercier Serge Babari et Sylviane Noël
qui ont retiré leurs questions puisque
déjà posées voilà
Madame la Directrice générale le menu
est large menu riche je vous remercie de
questions voilà je voudrais excuser je
vais t'oublier moi-même de partir donc
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne va venir
voilà présider à ma place mais voilà je
voulais m'excuser je ne pourrais pas
écouter jusqu'au bout voilà je vous ai
ma présidente messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs et sénatrices alors je vais je
vais essayer de regrouper certaines
points qui ont été soulevés mais tous
sont absolument
sont des questions évidemment sur
lesquelles on travaille peut-être pour
répondre au sujet de la 5G puisque c'est
la première question qui a été posée
donc le contexte énergétique et en rien
en fait orange n'est en retard sur les
plantes déploiement que nous avions
fixés donc nous nous sommes même les
plus avancés en France sur sur le
déploiement de la 5G on a priorisé
jusqu'à présent la 5G dans les zones
denses puisque c'est une façon pour nous
d'améliorer la qualité de service pour
pour nos clients et chaque fois qu'on
déploie de la 5G on voit le trafic qui
continue à augmenter on déploie le
territoire plus de 50% aujourd'hui 51 %
du territoire et des clients sont
couverts en 5g et on a un plan qui vise
à continuer et que l'on ne prévoit pas
de de changer en fonction du contexte
énergétique maintenant effectivement la
question est soulevée du nombre de sites
Télécom que l'on déploie puisque quand
on regarde notre équation énergétique et
ça rejoint la question qui a été
soulevée sur notre empreinte
environnementale en fait dans un réseau
ce qui consomme le plus ce n'est pas le
trafic et le trafic est un des
indicateurs qui augmentent la
consommation et les émissions c'est
d'abord le nombre de sites ce qui fait
que quand on regarde l'empreinte
environnementale d'orange le nombre de
sites en France continue à augmenter
mais mais beaucoup moins que ce que l'on
fait en Afrique et donc en fait notre
premier enjeu pour atteindre notre
neutralité carbone ça va être d'abord de
caper ou en tout cas de trouver des
moyens de déployer des nouveaux sites
mobiles avec des solutions d'énergie
renouvelables des systèmes de batterie
des choses qui vont nous inscrire dans
des solutions durables et
environnementales maintenant quand on
revient sur la 5G en France aujourd'hui
on déploie la 5G comme prévu et j'allais
dire notre véritable enjeu et ça a été
soulevé effectivement la 5G les usages
de la 5G ont été conçus d'abord pour des
usages industriels et pour des enjeux
d'aménagement de territoire des enjeux
et on le voit quand on quand on déploie
la 5G dans le port du Havre par exemple
ou à Anvers et là ces usages là par
contre Orange a été précurseur on a on a
lancé on a des cinq gélabs partout dans
le monde mais on en a plusieurs en
France sur lesquels on travaille avec
des industriels avec le l'écosystème de
la recherche pour finalement créer les
usages qui sont ceux que la 5G permet
d'imaginer au delà j'allais dire des
usages classiques des consommateurs qui
sont finalement toujours plus de bandes
passantes plus de rapidité et de et
d'efficacité énergétique aussi voilà
donc la 5G ça va rester encore un sujet
pendant très longues années il y avait
une question sur la 6G ou la 7g même
alors je peux vous assurer on a
évidemment des experts qui travaillent
au niveau mondial sur les enjeux de
standardisation de la 6G on en est
encore que là
mon humble avis dans l'équation
économique dans laquelle on est c'est
qu'on vient à peine de payer des
licences de 5g on est encore en train de
déployer des réseaux chose qu'on ne fait
pas encore en Afrique on a à peine
inauguré en Afrique 1 il y a un pays
dans lequel on commence à déployer la 5G
donc on est loin de parler déploiement
de la 6G et je pense que dans le
contexte économique social que l'on
traverse notre priorité c'est de
rentabiliser et d'utiliser au maximum
les infrastructures que l'on déploie
aujourd'hui mais bien sûr nous avons des
experts qui travaillent déjà sur les
générations suivantes
la question des Caps sous-marins qui a
été posée à la fois sous l'angle des
perspectives stratégiques et des enjeux
de sécurité donc évidemment c'est
quelque chose que de sur lequel d'abord
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir les
infrastructures que nous avons au niveau
mondial de capsoumin et notre activité
orange marine qui nous permet de poser
et de faire de la maintenance de câbles
de câble sous-marin c'est évidemment une
activité très stratégique puisque même
si tout le monde imagine que les
télécoms passent massivement par les
satellites la réalité c'est que 99% du
trafic passe par des câbles sous-marins
et que c'est ces réseaux sont redondants
sont sécurisés mais que nous avons
nous-mêmes pris la décision de renforcer
la sécurité depuis maintenant quelques
mois en particulier sur les points
d'amerrissage qui sont les endroits où
les câbles sous-marins arrivent sur
Terre puisque ce sont évidemment des
noeuds très critiques stratégiques de la
même façon que j'allais dire les câbles
terrestres puisque on a vu y compris en
France des cas de sabotage qui n'ont pas
toutes les infrastructures d'oranges
mais qui ont touché certains de nos
concurrents et c'est des sujets sur
lesquels nous travaillons main dans la
main avec l'ensemble de nos concurrents
puisque évidemment si on voit arriver ce
type de comportement sur les
infrastructures ce sont des ce sont des
sujets absolument critiques que nous
prenons au plus haut niveau
un point évidemment sur le sujet très
global de la fibre des sous-traitants de
la qualité de l'expérience pour nos
clients sur le déploiement de la fibre
c'est-à-dire ma première remarque en
arrivant chez Orange avec avec mes
réflexes de
d'industriels on va dire et les enjeux
de qualité c'est que c'est vrai que le
déploiement de la fibre aujourd'hui et
je reviendrai évidemment sur tout
l'enjeu de filière et les sous-traitants
l'expérience la qualité du déploiement
on est à des niveaux d'échecs en fait
qui ne sont pas du tout acceptables dans
plein d'industries c'est-à-dire que
quand on est à des taux d'échecs qui
sont parfois jusqu'à 20 ou 30% sur des
raccordements d'entreprises le coût de
non qualité pour l'entreprise orange est
alors on a ce sujet là nos concurrents
ont ce même ce même sujet là mais c'est
évidemment un sujet
économique d'expérience client et puis
de très très grandes frustrations pour
pour les techniciens d'orange évidemment
qui ont en plus le sentiment de se dire
mais c'est pas possible on sait faire
pourtant alors c'est vrai que j'ai fait
moi-même des visites terrain pour
comprendre finalement et tout ce que
vous avez dit est vrai c'est des sujets
sur lequel on travaille orange avec la
filière on a pris des engagements forts
on met en place des mesures alors on est
victime de la de la bulle de croissance
et quelque part déployer la fibre en
France en 15 ans
c'était en soi de toute façon un
chantier titanesque qu'on a mis 40 ans
pour le cuivre on a mis 80 années pour
le réseau électrique donc de faire en 15
ans ce qu'on avait fait en 40 ans pour
le cuivre malheureusement ça entraîné de
la non qualité parce que le juste le
besoin de main d'oeuvre effectivement
dépasser largement les finalement la
disponibilité de et la formation donc ça
a amené des dérives sur lequel on a
beaucoup travaillé au niveau de la
filière et chez Orange on a mis en place
un nouveau contrat RC centrique le 1er
avril qui visait justement à remettre la
qualité au plus haut niveau dans nos
contrats empêcher ce que vous citiez
c'est-à-dire de la sous-traitance de
rang 2 3 c'est à dire que bien sûr on a
un certain nombre de grands partenaires
qui sous traitent une partie de
l'activité mais on allait dans des
situations où il y avait de la
sous-traitance de rando de rang 3 etc
sans qui est évidemment des enjeux de
qualité des enjeux de formation
adapté et puis on est dans un modèle
compliqué puisque effectivement
il y a l'opérateur d'infrastructures il
y a l'opérateur commercial il y a les
travaux en zone privée pour le client et
ce que vous disiez sur la formation des
services commerciaux finalement pour
expliquer aux clients ce qui va se
passer entre le poteau qui arrive et qui
est l'infrastructure le réseau
d'infrastructures ou arrive la fibre le
point de mutualisation et puis arrivé à
passer par les gaines pour arriver
jusqu'au tableau où là où passe le
cuivre c'est des choses qui sont très
très complexes c'est des sujets sur
lesquels on travaille ça revient à la
question que je soulevais dans mes
propos qui vont être comment puisque
évidemment un certain nombre de
raccordement sont des raccordements
complexes avec des travaux nécessaires
en zone privée mais en tout cas on
travaille et avec nos sous-traitants et
on a mis en place nous on a renforcé
aussi d'une part les mesures de
prévention c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
beaucoup d'audit de prévention sur les
points de mutualisation on a investi
beaucoup nous-mêmes sur notre
infrastructure pour remettre à niveau
les fameux points de mutualisation dont
tout le monde a vu ces images de fibres
plates spaghettis et donc c'est des
choses et les techniciens c'est pas
quelque chose qu'ils aiment faire parce
que ça leur prend 48 heures c'est un
travail absolument fastidieux néanmoins
absolument indispensable et je peux vous
assurer que d'ailleurs que ce soit les
sous-traitants ou les techniciens
d'orange ou de nos concurrents personne
n'est fier quand ce type de situation
arrive néanmoins nous on investit
beaucoup évidemment pour mettre à niveau
quand il y a manifestement des problèmes
qualité certains de nos concurrents ont
encore beaucoup à faire sur leurs
infrastructures et mais là c'est le rôle
du régulateur aussi de faire le suivi et
puis ensuite il y a la maintenance dans
le temps de ce niveau de qualité et là
c'est là où dans nos contrats on met en
place aussi au niveau de la filière et
ça rejoint la question qui se souvient
la question de la traçabilité de garder
à jour finalement les cartes etc c'est
des sujets sur lesquels on utilise aussi
les nouvelles technologies avec des
photos avant après des vidéos et de la
traçabilité grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle donc il y a beaucoup de
choses que l'on met en oeuvre qu'on n'a
pas pu mettre en oeuvre dont j'allais
dire dans l'urgence du déploiement mais
maintenant toute la filière a pris ce
sujet au plus haut niveau et puis on
continue à travailler alors après j'ai
la carte des points noirs et selon
évidemment les les géographies où vous
êtes on sait qu'en particulier il y a
certains réseaux d'infrastructures qui
ne sont pas au bon niveau alors qu'ils
sont si c'était ceux détenus par Orange
je pourrais faire quelque chose quand
c'est le pire de la situation et je peux
vous assurer que le service client
d'Orange et j'ai parlé avec de nombreux
collaborateurs c'est une énorme
frustration pour eux d'avoir au
téléphone des clients qui se plaignent
et eux-mêmes disent mais en fait on n'a
pas les mains puisque l'infrastructure
elle est pas chez Orange et ça c'est la
vraie transformation au sein de
l'entreprise orange qui a eu l'habitude
d'être l'opérateur d'infrastructures et
qui a ce réflexe finalement de service
client parce que on a pris cette
responsabilité on se retrouve dans un
nouveau un modèle d'infrastructure sur
la fibre où effectivement orange n'est
pas propriétaire on a 60% j'allais dire
des déploiements fibres en France 50% en
propre 10% avec nos réseaux
d'initiatives publiques et dans 40% des
cas l'infrastructure elle n'est pas la
propriété d'orange et donc on doit gérer
cette interaction entre l'opérateur
commercial orange et les opérateurs
d'infrastructures donc c'est des choses
sur lesquelles les processus se mettent
en place les gens apprennent à se
connaître mais c'est vrai qu'on va
encore avoir pendant quelques mois on a
pris un certain nombre de mesures mais
il y a certains endroits où on sait
qu'on a encore des difficultés et
évidemment c'est c'est les collectivités
ou les communes dans lesquelles sur
lesquelles vous avez fait référence en
tout cas soyez assurés que c'est des
sujets que l'on prend en plus haut
niveau qui sont suivis également par le
régulateur et sur lequel on a bien la
détermination à finalement mettre en
place un réseau digne digne de ce nom
mais avec cette difficulté finalement du
raccordement client et qui est parfois
encore plus complexe quand il s'agit il
s'agit d'entreprises
le cas de la effectivement vous avez
soulevé le cas de la de la Scopelec sur
lequel on a moi dès mon arrivée on a
échangé et on a beaucoup travaillé
notamment sous l'égide du Syrie qui
était évidemment impliqué dans la dans
la dans l'accompagnement de la Scopelec
il y a un processus de redressement qui
est en cours mais pendant ce processus
l'entreprise ne s'arrête pas donc la
Scopelec a encore et à aujourd'hui des
contrats avec Orange dans certaines
géographies la qualité
où ils avaient du mal à continuer parce
que ils avaient des problèmes de
recrutement comme d'autres entreprises
d'ailleurs et donc on est on les a
appuyés dans d'autres régions ça se
passe très très bien donc évidemment il
y a à la fois le processus de reprise et
de redressement judiciaire mais sur le
terrain en tout cas les les contrats
continuent puisque la Scopelec a certes
perdu des parts de marché dans le
nouveau contrat avec Orange mais à
garder donc ça reste pour nous un
partenaire important et donc on de très
près sous l'égide du Syrie avec le
processus de redressement judiciaire
vous êtes revenu évidemment sur le sujet
du délestage et c'est vrai que je l'ai
peut-être pas mentionné mais quand on
parle de se préparer toutes les les
exercices de crise qu'on a fait prévenir
nos clients prévenir nos salariés parce
que vous parliez du télétravail mais
évidemment qu'est-ce qui enfin voilà les
salariés de toutes les entreprises ont
toutes les entreprises en France je vais
dire travail alors communication sur
l'enjeu du télétravail on travaille
beaucoup avec nos clients entreprises
puisque vous l'avez dit à juste titre
alors certains clients ont des
infrastructures critiques et ont des
systèmes énergétiques sont eux-mêmes en
discussion avec enedis ou RTE sur les
solutions de secours et pour éviter
d'être délesté mais on n'est pas sûr et
donc on envoie des courriers à nos
clients pour les prévenir on n'est pas
sûr que les solutions de communication
fonctionneront partout s'il y a des
stages donc effectivement
ce que vous ce que je disais sur le il y
a les consommateurs il y a le grand
public les entreprises les
administrations alors dans la mesure du
possible on va parler de des stages qui
seront sur des plages horaires définies
et donc voilà toute ce qu'on pourra
faire en communication en avance de
phase on le fera au maximum y compris on
s'inscrit évidemment dans cette dans
cette logique de communication et de et
d'information de nos clients que ce soit
sur sur les pages oranges TV ou en
communication par SMS on sera on sera au
rendez-vous pour prévenir nos clients
d'abord pour essayer d'éviter donc dans
toute la logique de la campagne Ecowatt
et puis évidemment ensuite pour se
préparer à cette situation qui est très
nouvelle en France mais j'ai envie de
dire malheureusement dans beaucoup de
pays
des solutions enfin des situations de
blackout ça arrive on est opérateur en
Moldavie la Moldavie est alimentée en
électricité massivement par l'Ukraine
donc on a en Moldavie des répétitions
malheureusement
sérieuses sur laquelle voilà les les
réseaux tombent le réseau d'électricité
tombe les solutions de backup reprennent
voilà donc il y a beaucoup de pays en
fait dans le dans l'environnement au
sein du groupe Orange dans lesquels on a
malheureusement pour des enjeux plutôt
sécuritaires on a eu à l'habitude de
gérer ce type ce type de situation donc
les techniciens s'affairent notre enjeu
ça va être massivement la communication
et puis évidemment des enjeux de
responsabilité quand on parle des
numéros d'urgence ou quand on parle de
continuité d'activité donc évidemment
nous on met en oeuvre nos plans de
continuité d'activité comme toutes les
entreprises en France et on les
accompagne quand on est leurs
fournisseurs sur les sur les lots
télécoms bien sûr
la question des poteaux et de la
maintenance des poteaux alors le
décomissionnement du cuivre ne veut pas
dire absolument pas que Orange et les
infrastructures de génie civil que sont
les poteaux ou les gaines enterrées ne
sont pas importantes pour Orange bien au
contraire on continue
d'investir sur cette infrastructure on
utilise d'ailleurs cette infrastructure
pour le cuivre c'est une infrastructure
qui est dans les tarifs sont réglementés
puisque certains n'ont concurrents sur
les infrastructures utilisent aussi
cette infrastructure donc c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on va on va continuer
on va continuer à investir après la
question de la est-ce que avoir de la
fibre en aérien c'est plus résilient que
en souterrain
il y a
oui et non c'est à dire qu'on voit tous
les cas de figure et je peux vous
assurer qu'il y a des pays le Japon par
exemple qui déploie massivement en
aérien puisque dans des pays où il peut
y avoir des tremblements de terre en
fait de réparer des réseaux quand c'est
en aérien ça se fait beaucoup plus vite
que quand c'est en souterrain on a vu
l'expérience de la de la vallée de la
Vésubie où il y a eu malheureusement
des catastrophes naturelles il y a il y
a deux ans tous nos réseaux étaient
enterrés ils ont été complètement
emportés par les inondations donc on a
tout reconstruit mais voilà donc
malheureusement
le l'enterrer n'est pas forcément plus
résilient que le que l'aérien mais c'est
évidemment des sujets que l'on regarde
au cas par cas il y a pas de il y a pas
de politique de politique générale mais
mais les poteaux et notre infrastructure
de génie civil sont absolument clés et
on a des programmes de prévention que
l'on met que l'on met en œuvre
la question vous êtes plusieurs à
reposer la question des enjeux de
souveraineté de sécurité du marché des
entreprises et de nos ambitions
évidemment dans la dans la cybersécurité
ou dans tous les enjeux de souveraineté
alors c'est quelque chose évidemment sur
lequel on est on est positionné et
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
l'entreprise a effectivement investi
dans la cybersécurité avec la création
de notre filiale Orange cyberdéfense en
début d'année en tout cas le
regroupement de toutes nos activités
dans cette dans cette filiale qui
effectivement vise et on atteindra un
milliard de chiffre d'affaires en 2023
avec cette activité donc c'est une
activité dans laquelle on a on a on a
vocation à continuer à investir et à la
développer de façon organique et non
organique l'enjeu des PME que vous êtes
plusieurs à avoir soulevé est absolument
critique et vous le savez les chiffres
le prouvent plus d'une PME sur deux qui
subit une attaque cyber mais la clé sous
la porte dans les six mois qui suivent
la taxi Berre donc c'est c'est un en
économique majeure qui est pris
évidemment au plus haut niveau par par
voilà les autorités par vous-même et par
nous acteurs et c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on a déjà quelques offres que
l'on a lancé alors plutôt à destination
des pros et des toutes petites
structures mais que l'on vise à enrichir
parce qu'évidemment aujourd'hui quand on
accompagne des grands groupes on est sur
des sur des enjeux qui sont en général
internationaux qui nécessitent c'est des
groupes qui eux-mêmes sont équipés avec
des compétences quand on s'adresse à des
PME à des patrons de PME ils ne savent
pas par où commencer et donc l'enjeu
c'est d'abord de faire effectivement des
audits et que eux-mêmes puissent faire
simplement des audits de situations et
puis qu'ensuite on puisse mettre des des
patchs plus rapides possibles pour
éviter effectivement les crises et puis
ensuite qu'on puisse les accompagner et
c'est aussi ce que l'annecy fait un
travail formidable d'accompagnement et
d'éducation mais tout commence par
l'éducation la formation et les enjeux
d'emploi associés puisque il y a plus de
350 000 postes non pourvu au niveau
mondial sur la cybersécurité nous même
orange on forme que ce soit des
collaborateurs en interne que l'on forme
pour aller dans ces métiers là et puis
on travaille évidemment avec les écoles
on a des partenariats en France et en
dehors de France et c'est quelque chose
sous lequel on a on devra tous continuer
à investir en tout cas c'est des métiers
porteurs sur lesquels malheureusement si
je puis dire mais voilà la pénétration
du numérique dans toutes les dans toutes
les strates on va dire de nos
organisations amènent avec un besoin de
renforcement de sécurité sur sur la
cyber
la question alors je reviens peut-être
sur le délestage il y avait la question
du 17h21 donc effectivement c'est des
sujets sur lesquels on travaille en
continu c'est quelque chose qui évolue
entre les annonces officielles se
répètent enfin au départ d'ailleurs on
nous disait aussi 21h et on travaille
pour essayer d'anticiper donc enedis
maintenant nous préviendrait quelques
heures plus tôt eux-mêmes sont prévenus
par RTE 2-3 jours plus tôt donc c'est
c'est tout le travail que l'on fait
entre maintenant j'allais dire et les
premiers cas qui arriverait puisque tout
ça reste encore très lié aussi aux
conditions météorologiques dont personne
finalement ne sait bien ce qu'elles
seront en tout cas les modèles
mathématiques peut-être mais nous ici
non et c'est des choses évidemment sur
lesquelles on va continuer à travailler
vraiment avec il y a deux aspects
puisqu'il y a évidemment la
communication vers nos clients et puis
le plus important pour nous c'est de
mettre en place les modèles
opérationnels qui feront que on
minimisera l'impact dans nos réseaux et
donc pour nos client et donc ça c'est
beaucoup de collaboration sur le terrain
et c'est l'objet des exercices de crise
que l'on a fait encore on en avait un
lundi ou mardi dernier au niveau
national donc c'est quelque chose sur
lequel on se prépare
mais la question effectivement des
solutions itinérantes de comment va
communiquer nous-mêmes vous les
collectivités tout le sujet des numéros
d'urgence c'est quelque chose évidemment
sur lequel on échange beaucoup avec le
gouvernement et on va continuer à le
faire dans les prochaines semaines
la question était posée du rôle des
collectivités et du sujet de la de la
communication sur le décomissionnement
du cuivre et vous avez raison puisqu'il
y a eu des abus et il faut pas que l'on
fasse peur aux Français le
décommissionnement du cuivre est quelque
chose qui s'inscrit dans le temps long
puisqu'on parle d'horizon 2030 sur
lequel oui il y aura besoin d'une
communication neutre qui peut pas être
une communication qui vient des
opérateurs et donc dans ce contexte là
les collectivités et le et le et le
gouvernement aura toute sa place nous on
a préparé un certain nombre de cahiers
pédagogiques pour expliquer tout ça mais
ce sont que des supports de
communication qui devront être relayés
et c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
aura évidemment besoin de travailler
main dans la main puisque pour que les
citoyens finalement il faut une
communication de confiance qui viennent
effectivement d'un tiers qui soit un
tiers de confiance neutre
la question je reviens sur la
cybersécurité alors c'est une question
que j'ai régulièrement plutôt par les
journalistes en général de la de
l'ouverture de la mise en Bourse de
notre activité de cybersécurité et ce
que je réponds toujours c'est que
la mise en Bourse c'est pas un projet en
soi enfin le financement d'une activité
c'est un moyen ce que je peux vous
affirmer déjà c'est que c'est une
activité importante pour Orange et
qu'effectivement d'ailleurs y compris
nos collaborateurs
craignent enfin je peux je peux imaginer
l'émotion si c'était la logique de on va
on va faire une mise en Bourse et puis
orange va plus s'y intéresser pas du
alors que c'est pas du tout le cas notre
enjeu c'est d'investir dans cette
activité on recrutera 600 collaborateurs
l'année prochaine en France sur cette
activité seulement on vise d'investir
comme je l'ai dit et donc on se posera
la question des moyens mais en aucun cas
la mise en Bourse est aujourd'hui un
sujet d'actualité puisque notre priorité
c'est bien c'est d'investir jusqu'à
présent on l'a fait sur les fonds
propres de l'entreprise je n'exclus pas
que on regarde d'autres d'autres moyens
pour accompagner la croissance de cette
activité mais ce que je peux vous dire
déjà c'est que c'est pas du tout un
sujet d'actualité et on reviendra
évidemment dessus avec enfin la
gouvernance de l'entreprise et lors de
nos présentations
stratégiques le sujet des satellites
aussi qui a été qui a été évoqué par
plusieurs d'entre vous alors c'est vrai
que Starlink fait beaucoup parler parce
que c'est lon musk l'actionnaire bon
alors quand alors il se trouve qu'au
orange à une filiale NordNet qui propose
des solutions
d'accès très haut débit par satellite
c'est quelque chose sur lequel alors le
nombre de questions que l'on reçoit
démontre à minima que l'on ne communique
pas assez sur ces solutions chez Orange
et que en particulier dans le dans la
question qui nous est soulevé
d'aménagement du territoire il est
évident que les solutions satellites
sont totalement complémentaires des les
autres solutions
c'est quelque chose d'ailleurs que l'on
fait très naturellement en Afrique
puisque le Bacall de site de site mobile
peut se faire par des faisceaux
hertziens mais dans certains cas les
solutions satellites sont les meilleures
solutions dans le cas de réseau d'accès
d'urgence dans les zones blanches
évidemment les solutions satellites sont
une réponse maintenant voilà donc c'est
complémentaire ça doit venir à côté et
c'est vrai que nous on a on a une
filiale en France NordNet et que et que
peut-être que on doit mieux communiquer
ou plus communiquer sur ces solutions là
puisque effectivement
Starlink n'a rien enfin en tout cas
orange n'a rien à envier à Starling et
Starlink reste une solution qui n'a pas
non plus pour des enjeux de souveraineté
on peut se poser la question nous nous
effectivement on utilise des bandes
passantes sur des satellites alors on
travaille que telsat mais mais on a
voilà des partenariats européens donc on
n'a pas vocation nous-mêmes à être
opérateur satellite mais par contre le
les solutions satellites en complément
absolument
la question absolument légitime de
l'impact environnemental du numérique
c'est quelque chose évidemment sur
lequel orange c'est déjà engagé depuis
un certain nombre d'années mais nous
devons la pression de va faire que
monter puisque le numérique est
aujourd'hui un faible émetteur de
carbone au niveau mondial par rapport à
d'autres domaines que peuvent être
évidemment l'industrie le bâtiment ou
les transports néanmoins c'est un
domaine si si on ne le met pas sous
contrôle et si on y travaille pas
activement il va peser dans le poids et
donc évidemment il est de notre
responsabilité et on le prend au plus
haut niveau
ça veut dire travailler comme on le fait
déjà depuis des années sur le fait que
nos réseaux doivent être efficaces en
énergie et en fait quand on a 30% de
croissance de trafic tous les ans de
stabiliser nos émissions carbone c'est
déjà un combat du quotidien que mène nos
équipes et ça passe par des
commissionnés des équipements
énergivores qui sont obsolètes ou qui
sont vieux et dans ce contexte là le
décomissionnement du cuivre pour le
remplacer par la fibre la fibre les
trois fois plus efficace d'un point de
vue énergétique que le cuivre donc ça va
dans ce sens là même chose la 2G la 3G
que l'on que l'on décomissionnera dans
les 10 prochaines années également en
tout cas dans les prochaines années même
pas dans les 10 prochaines années nous
aidera aussi à améliorer notre empreinte
environnementale et puisque je disais le
premier le premier vecteur de
consommation pour nous c'est d'abord le
nombre de sites c'est ensuite la
puissance effectivement de ces sites et
ensuite le trafic donc le nombre de
sites c'est évidemment plus en Afrique
que l'on investit puisque là il y a
encore beaucoup de couverture à mener
mais également en France et donc faire
en sorte que chaque site construit soit
avec de l'énergie renouvelable et que
l'on intègre dans le dans le design
les enjeux environnementaux c'est une
réalité et puis une grande partie de
l'empreinte numérique
l'EMP environnemental du numérique c'est
les terminaux et ça c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on est très engagé évidemment
c'est la fabrication des terminaux mais
ensuite c'est le cycle de vie des
terminaux orange est très engagé à
mettre en avant des solutions de
reconditionnement et donc on a un
programme re tout commence par la
collecte et puis la vente de
reconditionner évidemment le recyclage
en bout de chaîne si c'est plutôt que
plutôt que de ne rien faire de ces
terminaux et c'est un véritable enjeu
alors sur lequel on ne travaille pas
seul on travaille avec un écosystème
mais c'est ça fait partie de la de la
feuille de route pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone dans le numérique
sujet que la filière a pris au plus haut
niveau puisque on a des engagements
neutralité carbone en 2040 soit disant
avant avant les accords les accords de
Paris
peut-être dans les points alors il y a
une nombreuses questions donc je
reviendrai pas forcément sur sur tous
les tous les sujets mais le
l'innovation numérique en Afrique c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on est très
engagé on ouvre des ce qu'on appelle des
oranges digital Center notamment parce
qu'on est convaincu que le numérique est
aussi un énorme facteur d'inclusion et
donc la formation est finalement l'accès
à l'emploi grâce au numérique c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on est très
engagé alors en France comme en dehors
de France mais en particulier en Afrique
et puis on a des les solutions que
permettent finalement le mobile en
Afrique avec des solutions de paiement
et quelque chose qui est très très
vecteur aussi de développement
économique dans dans les pays en Afrique
et donc notre filiale Orange Money
finalement permet d'abord à des
distributeurs donc c'est des petits
points de vente de commercialiser et
donc on leur on leur on leur reverse une
commission et donc ça c'est évidemment
notre notre activité d'opérateur
économique mais ensuite Orange Money la
solution de paiement est elle-même une
brique absolument clé par exemple dans
le déploiement de kit de solaire plus
batterie dans certains villages pour
lesquels finalement les acteurs qui
veulent déployer ces solutions ne savent
pas comment les financer s'il n'y a pas
la brique de paiement associé que que
les acteurs comme Orange Money peuvent
apporter donc on est un acteur
évidemment clé dans l'innovation du
numérique en Afrique en plus de tout ce
que l'on fait évidemment en France
je reviens peut-être est-ce qu'il y a
des points
on a parlé du déploiement de la fibre
une question par rapport à la
structuration de la recette ou des
tarifs voilà m3 en trois pôles est-ce
que vous pouvez dire quelque chose
là-dessus et éventuellement ça
obligation
que j'ai travaillé chez Alcatel donc je
vois ce que ce qu'une industrie voilà
dans le temps peut amener alors c'est on
est sur des cycles très très long en
fait quand les modèles économiques ne
fonctionnent pas mais c'est vrai que
dans les télécoms
à marche forcée l'ouverture de la
concurrence et la politique industrielle
qui a été très tournée vers le prix pour
le consommateur ce que je disais mais
une énorme pression sur le financement
des infrastructures et donc pendant
la première décennie on a une régulation
qui visait l'ouverture des télécoms et
donc là tout était fait pour finalement
favoriser l'adoption de l'ADSL sur le
cuivre et puis la montée en puissance la
vente de licence et la création de
nouveaux opérateurs mobiles la décennie
2010-2020 a vu pour Orange une division
par plus que deux des cash flow générés
par l'entreprise
et c'est le cas de tous les grands
opérateurs historiques si vous regardez
ce qui se passe en Italie avec Télécom
Italia qui se scind en deux si vous
regardez dans d'autres on arrive
effectivement à ce contexte ou des
opérateurs c'est de leurs
infrastructures
et vous ne m'entendrez pas dire que les
infrastructures ne sont pas stratégiques
pour un opérateur
et donc ça veut dire que des opérateurs
qui cèdent leurs infrastructures c'est
des opérateurs ce qu'a fait téléphonique
en Espagne téléphonica a vendu ses tours
avant du sédata Center a vendu une
partie à défaut c'est le seul moyen de
faire pour beaucoup d'opérateurs quand
on n'a pas le choix que de rembourser
ses dettes ou de financer la 5G ou la
fibre et donc on est dans ce contexte là
et c'est bien cette prise de conscience
que l'on doit avoir au niveau européen
que le modèle économique aujourd'hui des
télécoms ne favorise pas
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures quand on voit arriver
des fonds privés qui rachètent ce type
d'actifs qui eux ont bien compris que
dans la durée il y aura des opérateurs
pour payer un prix de location sur ces
infrastructures on voit bien et que
alors que les marchés finalement ne
financent plus on voit bien qu'on a un
modèle qui ne tiendra pas dans la durée
ou en tout cas qui ne permettra pas de
garantir la souveraineté dans le temps
de ces infrastructures si on ne le prend
pas à temps il est pas trop tard et je
pense que ce que je disais le
commissaire Thierry Breton on a
conscience mais c'est pas quelque chose
qui est évident aujourd'hui en tout cas
ça va nécessiter une prise de conscience
et un changement effectivement de modèle
et il y a il y a au moins deux choses
qui sont importantes la première la
neutralité du Net est une valeur
absolument critique en Europe et je
pense que en aucun cas il ne faut la
remettre en cause parce que ça ça
détruirait finalement alors certaines
parties du monde
voilà dans certaines départements est
menacé en Europe c'était absolument un
principe absolument clé qui est
fondateur dans les valeurs et dans la
confiance dans le numérique maintenant
il faut de l'équité et sur le sur le
alors je parlais de du financement des
infrastructures cuivre et le sujet du
tarif des groupages c'est un exemple de
sujet où on a aujourd'hui une
tarification qui est très très morcelé
mais qui ne regarde pas l'équation
économique de bout en bout maintenant
dans le débat que l'on a avec les grands
fournisseurs de contenu
internationaux qui aujourd'hui captent 5
plus de 50% voire 70% aux heures de
pointe du trafic on voit bien qu'on a un
modèle où leur modèle par nature est
basé sur de l'augmentation de trafic
puisque plus les gens consomment plus
les gens regardent leur contenu plus il
se rémunère et plus nous même nous
sommes condamnés investir donc là on est
dans une équation qui ne tient pas on
est convaincu et c'est des acteurs avec
lesquels on ne peut pas nous alors nous
on est orange on est on est quand même
voilà onzième opérateur mondial mais
imaginez ce que c'est pour des plus
petits opérateurs y compris nos
concurrents français donc c'est quelque
chose sur lequel si l'Europe ne nous
aide pas en donnant un cadre et en
forçant finalement un cadre de
négociation obligatoire avec ces acteurs
là et l'enjeu est bien de se dire
comment on va travailler avec on va
cibler certains acteurs et donc faut
mettre une limite mais la limite elle
est assez évidente parce que même des
acteurs comme Microsoft en fait pèsent
très très peu dans le trafic donc en
fait on détermine très très facilement
qu'elles sont ceux qui pèsent 15 20% du
trafic unitairement et donc c'est
Netflix ces méta c'est Amazon voilà
c'est on parle de cinq cinq grands noms
et là c'est de la négociation qui doit
être basée évidemment sur des sur des
critères
factuels parce que il faut quelque chose
qui soit qui donne une base de
négociation et c'est d'essayer sur
lequel nous-mêmes sommes force de
proposition alors entre opérateur on
travaille sur des propositions que l'on
fait au niveau de Bruxelles
la Commission veut instruire le dossier
Monsieur Thierry Breton et lui-même
commissaire térébenton et motivé mais
c'est vrai aussi que on nous demande de
rendre des comptes et je ne néglige pas
et je ne sous-estime pas la capacité
d'influence de ces acteurs là aussi qui
sont eux-mêmes des acteurs économiques
qui créent des emplois et qui veulent
défendre leur équation économique mais
je remets au coeur du débat le sujet des
infrastructures et du financement et de
la souveraineté des infrastructures par
opposition à la politique qui a
aujourd'hui été essentiellement axée sur
l'enjeu de prix pour le consommateur
final
je pense que on a balayé beaucoup des
points donc voilà
en tout cas oui Daniel salmon oui merci
je voudrais juste remettre au coeur de
cette histoire l'humain l'humain dans
tout cela je vous avais posé une
question sur votre responsabilité
sociale élargie avec vous vendez du
temps d'écran quelque part et on voit
bien tous les impacts sur la société de
ce temps d'écran donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quelques mots sur le
sujet merci
alors c'est vous avez parfaitement
raison et on est très conscient de du
besoin d'éduquer au numérique ce qu'on
appelle numérique responsable donc on a
nous-mêmes on a un certain nombre de
campagnes publicitaires certaines
étaient
alors orientés autour de plutôt que de
regarder son écran va jouer au foot on
est donc le sujet du temps d'écran de la
protection des enfants de l'éducation au
bon usages du numérique ça fait partie
de notre GRC inscrit dans notre raison
d'être même dans les dans les dans les
statuts de l'entreprise et c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on travaille beaucoup y
compris sur la déconnexion quand on
parle de télétravail donc voilà tout ça
c'est évidemment des sujets absolument
clé on a finalement encore très très peu
de recul sur l'impact du numérique sur
nous humains alors il y a déjà beaucoup
d'études qui montrent que sur les
enfants les plus petits enfants c'est
évidemment le sujet des écrans est
quelque chose que l'on prend au plus
haut au plus haut niveau et donc on est
très très en sur ces sujets là et en
particulier dans avec cette cette
mission d'être de donner les clés à
chacun d'un numérique responsable donc
c'est chacun doit être libre de ses
choix mais à nous d'éduquer et de
permettre à chacun de faire des choix en
conscience et de façon informée
merci Madame la Directrice générale je
crois qu'il y avait encore une dernière
question de Jean-Pierre Bansard et après
on va vous libérer merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame directeur
général juste une petite question est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire s'il vous
plaît où ça en est aujourd'hui depuis la
création de la Banque orange aujourd'hui
où vous trouvez
alors l'activité orange Bank c'est aussi
une des questions sur lesquelles je suis
régulièrement interrogée par par les
médias et et l'activité orange Bank est
aujourd'hui un succès c'est-à-dire que
on a plus de 1 million quatre de clients
en France au rangement qu'elle a 3e
banque
numérique et mobile en France la
deuxième banque par notoriété maintenant
c'est une activité qui effectivement
n'est pas rentable et donc c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on est régulièrement
interrogé aussi par nos par nos
actionnaires et donc se pose la question
alors je reviens sur Elon Musk quand
Elon Musk investit avec des pertes dans
une activité tout le monde crie au génie
quand orange investi dans une activité
nouvelle qui nécessite parce que on est
en ligne avec le avec le plan d'affaires
qui avait été fait pour la banque on
savait qu'il fallait investir pendant
des années avant de pouvoir avoir de
générer des bénéfices maintenant c'est
vrai que ça pose la question de la de la
capacité pour Orange à tout faire à
financer cette activité là et donc dans
le cadre évidemment des réflexions
stratégiques pour l'entreprise on
regarde toutes les toutes les options y
compris le plus important qui est de se
dire finalement en quoi au rangement qui
est différent d'une banque parce que
quand orange Bank a été lancé beaucoup
de gens ont vu ça comme une idée de
génie puisque tout le monde a un
téléphone portable dans la poche et que
finalement la relation de chacun avec sa
banque elle passe bien plus par le
téléphone portable que par l'agence
bancaire et donc on a beaucoup travaillé
et le succès de rangement qu'aujourd'hui
c'est tous ces usages et ses offres qui
sont très très adaptées aux spécificités
de l'opérateur donc ça c'est quelque
chose que l'on a vocation à garder parce
qu'une fois de plus on vient enrichir
l'expérience pour nos clients Telecoms
mais ça ne veut pas dire que l'on doit
tout faire nous-même et donc c'est
évidemment les réflexions dans laquelle
dans laquelle on est mais je je
m'inssure je compte l'idée qu'au range
banques est un échec et que rangement
que ne fonctionne pas par contre
effectivement tel que le plan d'affaires
était défini c'est une activité qui
n'est pas encore
et bien merci beaucoup Madame la
Directrice générale pour cette première
audition pour le temps que vous nous
avez consacré le nombre important de
questions qui vous ont été posées
témoignent en tout cas de l'intérêt de
la commission des affaires économiques
pour tous les sujets liés aux
télécommunications au numérique et on
vous remercie très sincèrement et on
remercie bien sûr l'ensemble des
collaborateurs qui vous ont accompagnés
pour cette audition merci beaucoup et
bonne continuation à vous et à bientôt
espérons merci à vous